Hallo Chatge, ich hoffe Windows hat man wieder nicht an den Settings rumgestellt.
Aber jetzt erstmal warten bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass ich on bin. Ich war ja jetzt bestimmt schon 3 Wochen nicht mehr da.
Oder 4 Wochen nicht mehr da. Ah, ich glaube 3 Wochen.
Also okay, Twitch sagt 25 Days Ago.
Wobei das glaube ich nicht ganz stimmt, weil ich eine Streams gelöscht habe.
Schön, dass ihr da seid, Leute. Ich freue mich.
Not, not dead kill.
Beziehungsweise nicht, nicht dead kill.
Moin Michael, 5 Speljahre. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ah, ja, ja.
Schön, dass ihr da seid.
Ich bin auch nicht allzu lange on.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal sagen, ich bin noch am Start.
Was war los? Ich hatte echt so krasse Erkältung, Alter.
Aber das, das war schlimmer als Corona, Mann.
Nicht dead kill, ne.
Das war schlimmer als Corona.
Ah, das war richtig krass, ey.
Ich konnte nicht schlafen von der Erkältung, weil der Hals so dick war und alles, ey.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Moin Leon, danke schön für den Sub.
Jetzt geht's wieder. Jetzt geht's wieder halbwegs, ja.
Ich hab noch ein bisschen...
Gut, ich hör mich ja, manche Leute sagen, ich hör mich immer so an, als hab ich die Nase verstopft.
Aber ein bisschen, ein bisschen ist noch, ein bisschen ist noch.
Es geht aber seit letzter Woche, geht's eigentlich wieder aufwärts.
Also diese Woche war ich auch schon Dienstag in Frankfurt auf der Arbeit.
Und, mein gut, heute ist Tag der Deutschen Einheit, das ist keine Arbeit.
Heute, aber, Leute, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Passives Einkommen wird heute generiert.
Passives Einkommen und das ganz ohne WhatsApp-Gruppe.
Stonks, ja.
Tona, hello.
How do you say, long time no see?
Could it be that our Giga-Chat-Discord is closed?
I didn't find it last time I looked in Discord.
Yes, it's our Giga-Chat-Discord.
Only Giga-Chats allowed.
But thank you.
Und danke sehr.
Life-Mate, alles.
Sehr zu, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, Chat, heute ist passives Einkommen.
Stonks.
Splixer, danke für das.
Jetzt geht's aber los jetzt.
Das übertreibt man nicht.
Passives Einkommen heute.
Wollte ich euch ja erzählen.
Ich mache Rufbereitschaft am Tag der Deutschen Einheit.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass irgendwas ist, dass es quasi wie passives Einkommen generiert.
Mir, du.
Jetzt geht's aber los hier.
Freue dich auch am Start.
Fuck.
Alter, Leute.
Ich bin froh, dass ich wieder am Start bin.
Ich mache mal kurz die VM-An- und Updates.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die richtige VM ist.
Ist das da?
Ja, ey.
Habt ihr das?
Leute, habt ihr das Video vom Krieger gesehen?
Mega krass.
Ey, wenn nicht, wir können uns das auch nochmal angucken.
Klar.
Ja, hier.
Ja.
Ich hatte einen Schlaganfall im Livestream.
Das können wir nachher nochmal zusammen gucken.
Ich fand das echt...
Ziemlich erschreckend.
Ja.
Weil der Krieger ist vier oder fünf Jahre älter als ich.
Irgendwie so vier oder fünf.
Also ich bin jetzt 40.
Ich glaube, er ist 44.
Wird 45.
Ich bin dieses Jahr 40 geworden.
Also ich...
Es ist schon ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen...
Mon KS.
Ja.
Also er ist vier oder fünf Jahre älter.
Wo ich so lange war...
Ey, ich war übelst halb dead.
Ich hatte so eine krasse Erkältung.
Und ich konnte nicht mal schlafen durch die Erkältung, weil der Hals so dick war.
Oder sich so angefühlt hat, dass ich irgendwie keine Luft krieg.
Es war schlimmer als Corona, Leute.
Und Corona war schon scheiße.
Vielleicht war es auch Corona.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht war es auch wieder Corona.
Vielleicht war es auch Corona.
Ich habe keinen Test gemacht.
Obwohl ich noch unten einen 30er-Pack oder sowas habe.
Ich hatte...
Ich habe mir mal...
Ihr kennt ja meine Taktik.
Wenn ich was bestelle bei Amazon...
Bei Amazon...
Oder bei AliExpress oder sonst wo.
Ich bestelle ja nie einzelne Packungen.
Gerade bei so Sachen, wie man verbraucht.
Also habe ich damals auch irgendwie einen...
Fragt mich nicht.
50er oder einen 2x30er-Pack oder irgendwie sowas.
Corona-Tests.
Bestellt.
Ich habe jetzt wirklich genug Corona-Tests für immer.
Aber ich habe keinen gemacht.
Vielleicht war es ja auch Corona.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe aber keinen...
Ich glaube nicht.
Also es hat sich ein bisschen...
Anders angefühlt als Corona.
Okay.
Tracker 3 wird ersetzt durch Tiny Sparkle.
What?
Was zum Teufel ist überhaupt Tracker 3?
Low Footprint...
Chat.
Ich bin...
Ich bin zu low IQ dafür.
Was soll das bedeuten?
Oder Grippe?
Grippe kann es eigentlich nicht sein.
Dafür hatte ich nicht genug Fieber.
Ich hatte gar kein richtiges Fieber.
Ich hatte nur ein bisschen erhöhte Temperatur.
Also das spricht auf jeden Fall nicht für Grippe.
Grippe ist eher so 39 oder sowas.
Und bei Corona hatte ich auch...
Mit Ministerlein für den Zap.
Corona hatte ich auch höheres Fieber.
Also vielleicht war es auch Corona.
Also was ist ein RDF-Triple-Store?
Spark UL 1.0.
Leute, ich habe absolut kein Blastschimmer, was das sein soll.
What?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich...
Ganz ehrlich?
Wir brechen das jetzt einfach ab.
Und wir löschen...
Wecker 3.
Weil ich nicht weiß, wofür wir das...
Ach, GTK braucht das.
Warum braucht GTK irgendein SQL-Zeug?
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Egal.
Upgrade.
QEMU-Upgrade.
Yes.
Wir machen einfach eine volle Pull-Upgrade.
Wie gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Hat sich aber machen Spaßes halber.
Du meinst einen Corona-Test?
Nee, das mache ich jetzt nachträglich auch nicht noch.
Laufen die Dinger nicht ab?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich haben die irgendeinen...
Irgendeinen...
Verwenden sie es mindestens bis...
That's very roffel.
Ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, die Dinger funktionieren bestimmt auch noch nach dem Ablaufdatum.
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder so eine typische Geschichte von...
Ja.
Ähm...
Die laufen ab, dass du die gefälligst neu kaufen musst.
Wahrscheinlich läuft sogar Klopapier ab.
Es hat doch garantiert, wenn man irgendwo genau guckt, hat doch wahrscheinlich sogar Klopapier draufstehen.
Mindestens.
Oder...
Spätestens verwenden am...
Oder sowas.
Die neuen Virus...
Das stimmt.
Okay, Leute.
Leuchtet mir ein.
Ja, wieder am Start.
Stimmt.
Stimmt, ihr habt recht.
Wenn der die neuen Varianten...
Okay, das ist richtig so, ja.
Ja, okay.
Chat.
Lass es mir gefallen.
Leuchtet ein.
Dann kann ich den doch eigentlich wegschmeißen, oder?
Macht doch keinen Sinn, wenn ich irgendwie einen zwei Jahre alten Corona-Test...
Einen 20er, 30er Pack...
Zwei Jahre alten Corona-Tests hier noch rumliegen habe.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, den kann ich wegschmeißen.
Wie sieht es eigentlich deiner Meinung zum Thema Kopfhörer-Thematik aus?
Immer noch damals...
Du meinst, dass sich Headsets nicht lohnen?
Ja, das sehe ich prinzipiell immer noch so.
Oder was meinst du?
Also, ich bin der Meinung, dass ich so richtig krasse Game...
Sag mal, fehlt hier nicht irgendwas?
Chat.
Sollte nicht hier irgendwas sein an der Stelle?
Irgendwie so ein...
Switch-Turbo, oder?
Da fehlt doch was.
Also, ich denke, dass immer...
Also, ich bin immer noch der Meinung, dass sich so die super krassen Gaming-Headsets eigentlich nicht lohnen.
Für...
Also, ich muss das ein bisschen einschränken.
Ich habe das vielleicht zu...
Was soll ich sagen?
Was ist da schon wieder los?
Reboot.
Dann geht es bestimmt wieder.
Also, ja, das muss ich...
Das habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen zu allgemein.
Damals gesagt im Video so nach dem...
Oder alles Blödsinn, sonst wie.
Also, das ist nichts Schlimmes dabei, wenn man ein Gaming-Headset hat.
Ja, wenn man die Kombination will aus halbwegs gescheitem Kopfhörer und meistens ziemlich Low-Quality-Mikrofon, ist das okay.
Kann man das machen?
Machen genug Leute.
Es gibt ja auch Leute genug, die damit streamen.
Das ist jetzt nichts irgendwie Schlimmes.
Aber man muss halt sagen, gerade die Mikrofon-Qualität...
...ist bei den meisten Gaming-Headsets echt nicht gut.
Und die Kopfhörer kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, dass das halt so eine Range von Schrott bis ganz gut.
Also, ich finde nach wie vor das beste Headset, was es gibt, was du dir kaufen kannst, ist das Biodynamics MMX300.
Da bin ich übrigens gar nicht sicher, ob es da nicht endlich mal vielleicht irgendwie einen Nachfolger von gibt oder sowas.
Okay, es gibt einen MMX300 Pro.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Kann man hier irgendwie gucken nach Gaming?
Oh, die haben jetzt noch mehr.
Guck mal.
Die Astro-Dinger, die waren damals soundtechnisch richtiger Schrott.
Aber die haben sich halt gerade wegen dem Mix-Amp und sowas verkauft.
Okay, es gibt jetzt...
Okay, wir sind neuer.
Es gibt jetzt einen 330 Pro mittlerweile.
Aha.
BB-BB?
Was ist der Unterschied?
Okay, da muss ich mal gucken.
Das A50 ist, wie gesagt, für die meisten Sachen, gerade was Spiele angeht und auch so die meisten Online-Videos, das ist alles kein Ding.
Wenn man jetzt aber zum Beispiel das Headset auch verwenden will für, man sitzt am Rechner und hört sich irgendwie Konzertaufnahmen oder sowas an, ja?
Oder hat einen Film mit guter Audioqualität und will da wirklich was Gutes rausholen, dann ist jetzt vielleicht das Gaming-Headset nicht so das Beste.
Fürs Spielen und fürs Online ein bisschen Voice-Chatten und sowas, da reichen Gaming-Headsets auch.
Ich persönlich muss sagen, ich finde die Kombination aus gescheiten Kopfhörer und Mikrofon tatsächlich, also rein, wenn es mal um die Qualität geht, besser.
Zumal man auch relativ günstig gute Kopfhörer bekommt.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel auch von Biodynamic.
Da muss man sich aber ein bisschen genauer angucken, was man will.
Ich bin ja so ein kleiner...
Ich war ja...
Früher, ich habe lange keine mehr gekauft.
Ich war ja früher so ein kleiner Kopfhörersammler.
Ich habe hier an der Tür immer noch so ein Ding zum Aufhängen.
Da hängen immer noch ein paar Headsets, ja?
Da hängt zum Beispiel noch ein AKG...
Boah, was sind das für eins?
Ich kann gerade nicht hinlaufen, weil die Kabel nicht reichen.
Da hängt beispielsweise noch eins, so ein großes von AKG, noch von Audio-Technica eins.
Also ich habe da ein paar Kopfhörer, nicht Headsets, sorry, Kopfhörer, habe ich da hängen.
Und die haben alle einen gewissen Unterschied.
Die haben einen unterschiedlichen Klang, wenn man das mal vergleicht.
Da muss man halt gucken, was man will.
Grundsätzlich muss man sich dazwischen entscheiden, was für eine Bauart man haben will.
Also sprich, ob man lieber einen offenen Kopfhörer haben will oder einen geschlossenen, halboffenen Kopfhörer haben will.
Das hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, in welcher Umgebung man das verwenden will und ob man was von der Umgebung mitkriegen will.
Und beziehungsweise die Umgebung, was von euch mitkriegen soll.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde, also prinzipiell rein von...
Vom Wohlfühlfaktor finde ich prinzipiell offene Kopfhörer eigentlich am angenehmsten, weil du hörst halt alles, was drumherum ist.
Ja, du hörst noch, dass unten mal das Telefon klingelt oder dass einer an der Tür klopft oder sonst was.
Also wenn du ein bisschen was drumherum mitkriegen willst, ist ein offener Kopfhörer super.
Natürlich, wenn ihr im Büro sitzt mit einem offenen Kopfhörer und hast irgendwas an, dann hören das die Leute leise auch.
Oder, tja, je nachdem wie laut das ist, mehr oder weniger leise.
Das MMX-300 zum Beispiel.
Das ist ein...
Das ist ein geschlossener Kopfhörer.
Da kommt nix rein.
Also nix kann man nicht sagen.
Aber da kommt so gut wie nix rein und nix raus.
Das ist natürlich für Immersion und gerade wenn du irgendwie mit dem Shooter spielst und rumballerst und willst nicht, dass du die Leute, die hier bei dir in der Wohnung sind oder auch mit denen du zusammenwohnst oder sonst wie, auf den Sack gehst, ist das eine gute Sache.
Problem an geschlossenen Kopfhörern ist, wenn ich hier da sitze und schwätze und hab hier ein bisschen Musik an.
Ich höre nicht, wenn das Telefon klingelt.
Keine Chance.
Das höre ich vielleicht mit Ach und Krach, wenn es mal leise ist und ich ganz genau hinhöre, aber ansonsten höre ich da nix.
Ja.
Man redet auch lauter.
Das stimmt.
Das darf man auch nicht unterschätzen, wenn man geschlossen ist.
Herz hat, redet man lauter.
Deswegen ist der Trick bei mir, warum das nicht so ist.
Ich habe die an einem Audiointerface angeschlossen, was den Sound von meinem Mikrofon ein bisschen zurück einspielt in meinen Kopfhörer.
Also ich höre mich quasi selbst auf den Ohren leise, wenn ich, wenn ich jetzt hier reinrede.
Das ist natürlich wichtig, dass das verzögerungsfrei funktioniert, weil ansonsten hast du Brainlag.
Also wenn es, selbst wenn es nur 100, 150 Millisekunden zu spät ist, da kommst du dir permanent wie ein eigenes Echo vor.
Das ist natürlich Schrott.
Das muss instant sein.
Das muss quasi Lichtgeschwindigkeit sein.
Und dann ist das okay.
Ja.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich, ich höre mich selbst, ich höre mich selbst ein bisschen.
Und deswegen schreie ich nicht.
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder?
Warum ist das kaputt?
Was, was machen denn die Arsch?
By the way, Leute.
Paru funktioniert nicht mehr.
Aha.
Paru ist, okay, da ist es, sorry.
Yay, fails to compile and run with Pac-Man.
Okay, was muss man machen?
Äh, what?
Wir installieren, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Wir installieren das einfach neu.
Wir, wir installieren das einfach neu.
Also zum Nachinstallieren gibt es das ja wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ja eine extra, extra, wir installieren das einfach neu.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Guck mal da.
Wir, wir installieren das einfach neu und gut ist.
Das haben wir installiert.
Was ist das heutige Thema?
Dass ich nicht gestorben bin.
Dass es mich noch gibt.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Kann man keine Links mehr posten oder ist Mozilla prompt?
Ganz ehrlich, irgendwas ist mit dem Twitch-Chat gerade.
Du siehst auch, dass hier die Icons und so alle kaputt sind.
Ich refreshe mal kurz, vielleicht gehen dann die Icons wieder.
Aber beim Vorschau.
Vom Rechner ist es auch so.
Ah, guck mal.
Was, Twitch, what the fuck?
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Jetzt, jetzt funzen die Icons wieder.
Was auch immer da kaputt war.
So.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Bam.
Nice.
Dann updaten wir mal den Rest auch.
Einfach mal neu installiert.
Cooles.
Wundert mich eigentlich, warum ist Yay und Paru und Gedöns,
warum ist denn das nicht im offiziellen Anzeichen?
Ist das ein Arch-Repo eigentlich, dass man es mit Pac-Man installieren kann?
Das wäre doch, das wäre doch irgendwie naheliegend, oder?
Warum muss man das selbst bilden?
Heute Homeoffice?
Was?
Heute ist Feiertag.
Windows-App.
Was Windows-App, Remote-App wird umbenannt.
Nee, heißt nicht mehr Terminal-Desktop jetzt, oder was?
Oh, die Domain, Alter.
App-Gefahr.
Schon die frohe Kunde von Arch und Steam gehört.
Ja, habe ich irgendwie so am Rande gelesen.
Dass Valve jetzt irgendwie, irgendwie was Arch-mäßiges supporten will.
Und, und, und da war auch noch irgendwas mit Tails und sowas.
Aber ich habe es nur so am Rande gelesen, weil ich zu sick war letzte, letzte 14 Tage.
Also was?
Windows-App, Remote-App wird umbenannt und aktualisiert.
Okay.
Microsoft hat ja eigentlich Fernsteuer, Remote-Desktop nicht nur ein App.
Also, MSTSC, ne?
Das da.
Dieses Ding, was aussieht wie aus Windows XP.
Wahrscheinlich auch aus Windows XP ist.
Heute ist Tag der Deutschen Einheit.
Heute ist es nicht so, dass nur bestimmte Bundesländer Feiertage haben, sondern es sind tatsächlich alle Feiertage.
Microsoft hat den einen, auf den anderen versondern gleichzeitig auch ein Namensende.
Äh, wo ist eigentlich mein Darkreader hin, Leute?
Der weg?
Ach nee, den habe ich hier noch nie gehabt in Chrome.
Den hatte ich nur in Chromium, kann das sein?
Ja, hier, Darkreader, bam.
Also, ab sofort heißt die Remote-App Windows-App.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Gibt es irgendeine dümmere Bezeichnung für dieses Ding als Windows-App?
Windows-App.
Sind nicht alle Apps für Windows Windows-Apps?
Was, warum, warum ist Microsoft so kacke in der Benahmung?
Ich glaube, es geht um die Remote-Desktop-App für AVD.
Was ist AVD?
Azure Virtual Desktop oder sowas?
Also, aber der Name ist wirklich, der ist wirklich hängen geblieben.
Genau.
So, wer die Akte, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Die App sieht schon so abschreckend aus, findet ihr nicht auch?
Die sieht schon so aus, als will ich die nicht verwenden.
Ja, Microsoft.
Übrigens, Chatge, mal eine Frage an euch, an euch Windows-Admins.
Habt ihr?
Das müssen wir mal kurz hier installieren.
Habt ihr gelesen, dass WSUS eingestellt, WSUS eingestellt wird?
Dass Microsoft keinen Bock mehr auf WSUS hat?
Ist das gut oder schlecht, Windows-Leute?
Also ich, als jemand, der mit Windows und Windows-Support und Windows-Administration nichts zu tun hat,
würde, hätte jetzt gesagt, das ist schlecht, weil man Windows-Updates nicht mehr offline verteilen kann,
aber erklärt mir das mal.
Aber als Noob.
Ist das, ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Hat auch nie gut funktioniert, okay.
Reboot.
Ist Intune das neue, das neue WSUS quasi?
Aber, aber Intune kann man wahrscheinlich dann nur mit Azure und Cloud verwenden, oder?
Weil Microsoft will ja immer quasi Abo-Gebühren abgreifen.
Für Microsoft hat ja kein Bock, dass man das irgendwie selbst macht oder offline oder gar, gar ganz ohne Microsoft.
Intune ist Microsoft 365.
Ähm, ja, gut, dann, ja, dann ist es mit Abo.
By the way, zu Wort vor 21 Tagen in meiner Firma benutzen wir Eclipse für unsere Legacy.
Ernsthaft?
Ach so, ja gut, wenn ihr eigene Eclipse-Plugins haben und so, dann verstehst.
Ist bei uns, ist bei uns tatsächlich ein bisschen ähnlich.
Bei uns, äh, das ist dort, wo ich arbeite, die haben eigene Outlook-Plugins und die punsten halt nur bei diesem, bei diesem Classic-Outlook.
Wie nennt man das jetzt?
Altersalte.
Das, das Normale.
Normale Outlook halt.
Und finden das alle nicht so geil, dass man jetzt, dass es jetzt quasi ein neues Outlook gibt, was man bald verwenden muss.
Äh, gibt es hier einen Linux-Wert, der mir sagen kann, wie es sei, wie es sein kann, dass demnächst, stimmt deine Systemzeit nicht?
Oder stimmte deine Systemzeit vielleicht nicht bis vor kurzem?
Dass quasi Reboot war und nachdem er gestartet ist, irgendwie, äh, dann mal...
NTP gesynct hat.
Hast du Dual-Boot Windows-Linux?
Die kommen sich da gerne in die Quere, was Systemzeiten angeht.
Das ist eine VM.
Pff, äh.
Dann hätte ich, dann hätte ich gedacht, dann, dann würde ich sagen, die VM startet mit falscher Zeit.
Und, äh, synct sich dann erst im Startvorgang.
Aber dann müsste zumindest deine Ausgabe später dann richtig sein.
Hast du vielleicht die falsche Zeitzone gesetzt oder irgendwas?
Wie geht das nochmal, Lokale oder so?
Hast du da irgendwelche Dinger gesetzt?
Ne, wo setzt man überhaupt nochmal Zeit zu?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Alle Logs haben die richtige Zeit.
Dann habe ich keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Stimmt denn meins hier?
Ja, meins stimmt.
Meins wäre prinzipiell richtig.
Was ist das?
Kann ich das aufmachen, oder?
Was?
I got swatted and handcuffed live while Linux...
What?
Das habe ich verpasst.
Das ist mir komplett neu.
Was?
Was ist denn da los gewesen?
Darkseid, danke schön für den Sub.
Was ist denn, krass, was ist denn da los gewesen?
Da waren bestimmt die Rust-Leute dahinter.
Ach, was für ein Blödsinn.
Ich kenne, ich kenne die Videos nur so ab und zu von Empfehlungen.
Es ist ja sicherlich keiner, der krass gegen Rust flamed.
Und selbst wenn, deswegen swattet man noch keinen.
Alter, das ist ja krass.
Wussten die irgendwie, wo der wohnt, oder?
Krasser Scheiß, Mann.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass mal jemand...
...während Linux-Kernel-Development geswattet wird.
Generell, das ist wirklich was, wo ich den Leuten, die das mache,
echt wünsche, dass die dafür in den Knast kommen.
Weil das ist so ein krasser Eingriff,
sagen wir mal so, in die persönliche Persönlichkeit,
oder wie auch immer man es nennen soll,
und es ist ja auch gefährlich as fuck.
Ich meine, in Deutschland, vielleicht nicht ganz so gefährlich wie in den USA.
In den USA wurden ja schon Leute erschossen,
weil sie eine Wiimote am Handgelenk hatten und sowas.
Aber das ist krass.
Also, da hoffe ich, die finden die Leute dahinter,
und die kriegen richtig Ärger.
Und sind auch mal vielleicht ein bisschen für eine Weile weg vom Fenster.
Weil das kann sehr schnell sein.
Imagine never update schnell und backdokumented.
Genau.
Siehst du mal, das wird das neue Security-Meta.
Nicht mehr irgendwelche komischen russischen Entwickler.
Oder wie war das bei...
Wo war das hier mit dem...
Was war das letztens nochmal?
Nicht Log4j, das Nachlog4j.
Was fast in Debian Stable gelandet wäre.
LZM... Gibt es LZMA? Kann das sein?
XZ?
XZ, genau.
XZ, da haben die sich jahrelang oder monatelang in das Projekt...
Ja, gut, SSH war die Auswirkung, ja.
XZ.
Da haben die sich jahrelang quasi da eingeschlichen.
Warum sollte man sich einschleichen,
wenn du Kernelentwickler auch einfach swotten kannst und schnell was committen?
Aber das ist echt, das ist nicht lustig.
Eigentlich sollte man sich da nicht lustig drüber machen.
Also, ich hoffe, ernsthaft, die finden die Leute.
Und die sind mal eine Weile weg vom Fenster.
Weil das kann es nicht sein.
Ähm, es wird jemand geswottet wegen Linux Kernel, während der Kernel-Development-Stream, Mann.
Krasser Scheiß, Mann.
Ne, das habe ich nämlich nicht mitgekriegt.
Dafür war ich zu sickige die letzten, die letzten Tage.
Ja, wieder am Start.
Du hattest mal erzählt, dass du statt VPNs dir VPNs mit Pay-Per-Use verwendest und SSH-Tool machst.
Was gibt's da für...
Ähm, DigitalOcean.
Also, das Einzige, wofür ich ein VPN regelmäßig brauche,
ist YouTube Premium.
Aus Indien.
Und das mache ich über DigitalOcean.
Bangalore.
Genau.
Das ist in Indien.
Hört sich irgendwie ein bisschen unanständig an, aber es ist eine Region in Indien.
Die sind...
Man konnte mal irgendwann wieder hier auf Google Maps gehen, aber das funktioniert nicht.
Ja.
Also, die hat ja nur 11,4 Millionen Einwohner.
Läuft das noch?
Ich habe lange nicht mehr verlängert.
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen.
Das ist auch das, was ich die letzten Male dazu sagen konnte.
Also, ich habe ein indisches Payment-Profil, dass das überhaupt funktioniert hat.
So.
Also, hier miete ich mir eine VM in Bangalore.
Und darüber tunnel ich mich.
Das ist relativ einfach.
Ich kann es dir aus dem Kopf nicht sagen genau.
Es ist irgendwie SSH-N bla bla bla.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Du kannst zumindest mit SSH einen lokalen SOX-Proxy aufbauen.
Dann stellst du deinen Browser auf Localhost-Port...
Was ist SOX-1237?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Ne, minus L war was anderes.
Du willst ja keinen Port-Forwarding machen.
Du willst ja wirklich einen Proxy aufmachen.
SSH-SOX-Proxy.
Hier, SSH-D1237-QC.
Genau.
Das da in der Richtung.
C brauchst du nicht für Compression.
Ich glaube, N brauchst du...
Genau.
Und Quiet kannst du ja auch sparen.
Das machst du.
Dann sagst du hier, keine Ahnung, root at blub blub blub blub blub.
Hörst du das aus?
Dann hast du lokal auf deinem Rechner auf Port 1337
einen SOX-Proxy offen.
Und dann gehst du in deine Browser-Settings.
Proxy.
Und stellst dann quasi hier ein Localhost-1337.
Sorry, nicht hier.
Wahrscheinlich da, ja.
Und dann surfst du quasi über deine SSH-Verbindung und kommst in Indien raus.
IP-Leak.
Echt, wo?
Schau wieder.
IP-Leak.
Du meinst hier ein Localhost.
Ja, das ist krass.
Also das ist schon...
Das ist grenzwertig, dass ich das geleakt habe.
Local-Hosat.
Leaked.
Hier auch leaked.
Alles, alles leaked.
Warum nicht Port-Forwarding?
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Weil du mit reinem Port-Forwarding nicht surfen kannst.
Mit einem SOX-Proxy kannst du surfen.
Du willst im Endeffekt, dass dein Browser den kompletten Traffic quasi durch den Tunnel an den SOX-Proxy schickt.
Der SOX-Proxy durch den Tunnel und von dort dann quasi weitergeschickt wird mit Absender-IP von deiner VM.
Mit einer reinen Port-Forwarding kommst du da nicht hin.
Du kannst ja nur einen Port weiterleiten von zu.
Also was du wahrscheinlich machen könntest ist, wenn du...
Du könntest Port-443 weiterleiten wahrscheinlich auf die IP von der Google-Webseite, die du brauchst zum Verlängern deines Abos und dann lokalen DNS-Eintrag machen oder so komisches verrücktes Zeug.
Aber nachdem da nicht nur eine IP dran beteiligt ist, das ist nix.
Also das funzt nicht.
Du brauchst einen SOX-Proxy.
Und das ist wirklich die einfachste Variante per SSH.
Also hier...
Quasi über einen Proxy zu surfen.
Einfacher geht's nicht.
Du brauchst halt irgendwo eine VM als Endpunkt.
Das ist egal, ob du jetzt hier dir eine VM in Deutschland mietest, eine VM in NA, sonst wie.
Wofür es...
Wofür es nicht sonderlich gut ist, sind so Sachen wie Netflix-Region umgehen und sowas.
Also ich hab da jetzt noch keinen bandbreiten Test drüber gemacht und ich würde mal vermuten,
allzu schlecht ist die Bandbreite und Latency über SSH mit SOX-Proxy nicht, aber es ersetzt kein vollwertiges VPN.
Es funktioniert prinzipiell nur bei Sachen, die SOX-Proxys unterstützen.
Und...
Es ist sicherlich auch nicht sonderlich effizient.
Man sollte nämlich nicht vergessen, bei SSH drunter ist ja immer noch quasi so Textübertragung und sowas.
Also...
Ich glaube, die Bandbreite ist nicht so geil und die Latency ist auch nicht so geil.
Also wenn ihr sowas machen wollt, wie...
Netflix-Region-Log umgehen und solche Geschichten, dann würde ich sagen, nehmt halt einen VPN-Anbieter.
Oder, was ihr auch machen könnt, ist natürlich, euch eine VM mieten in der jeweiligen Region und selbst einen VPN drauf installieren.
Von WireGuard bis auf einen VPN bis...
Was ist da sonst alles so angesagt?
Zero-Tier oder was es da noch alles gibt?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Leute...
Ich muss mir mal ganz kurz...
Was zu trinken holen.
Bin ich wieder am Start.
Wieder am Start.
Ich muss mal kurz mein passives Einkommen...
...kontrollieren, Leute.
Ähm...
Nee, ist nix, okay.
Alles gut.
Hätte ja sein können, dass irgendein Alarm war und ich jetzt eigentlich Rufbereitschaft-Einsatz machen müsste.
Aber ist nix.
Äh, wer sich fragt, wie oft Rufbereitschaft-Einsätze bei uns sind, sehr selten.
Öff... Ich mein, es ist immer öfters, als man lieb... als einem lieb ist, aber es ist wirklich sehr selten.
Ja, also wenn du Dual-Boot-Windows-Linux machst, hast du öfters Probleme.
Mit Zeiten, die kommen sich da in die Quere.
Hast du das mit Reni...
Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Kenn ich nicht.
Nutzt du noch WLAN?
Ja.
Mehrere WLAN-Installationen jeden Tag.
Ich hab beispielsweise die Treppe, die vom Erdgeschoss in den ersten Stock geht.
Hab ich in...
Strip.
Streifen.
Meine Güte, Alter!
Deutsch-Denglisch, Mann!
LED. RGB-LED-Streifen.
Ach, das war der Swatter-Typ, ja. Jetzt hab ich...
Krasser Scheiß, ne? Jetzt hab ich's auch mitgekommen.
Da hab ich auch ein LED... also mehrere LED-Strips, Streifen, so in...
Wie sag ich das?
Wie ist denn eigentlich das korrekt... die korrekte Bezeichnung davon in Deutsch?
Ich sag immer LED-Strip.
Was sagt man da? Streifen sagt man doch dann nicht auf Deutsch, oder?
LED-Leiste oder sowas vielleicht?
Was ist denn da die... was ist denn da eine schöne deutsche Bezeichnung für?
Ben? LED-Pender vielleicht, ja?
LED-Band?
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, ja?
Hab ich drei Stück aneinander die Treppe hoch.
An der Seite. An der Seite vom... quasi... quasi unterm Geländer.
Sind LED-Strips.
Und die funktionieren mit WLED.
Ja.
Dann hab ich am Fenster hier was. Funktioniert auch mit WLED.
Dann hab ich ne selbstgebaute Lampe. Funktioniert auch mit WLED.
Äh...
Mein Weihnachtsbaum läuft mit WLED.
Aber den hab ich gerade nicht am Start, sonst...
Was hat man sonst noch?
Ob das war's?
Also ich hab einige WLED-Installationen.
Die sind nicht... die sind nicht wirklich aktuell.
Ich hab da WLED-Installationen, die sind drei Jahre alt oder so.
Aber...
Home Assistant macht das tadellos.
Ich nehm mir jedes Mal vor, wenn ich irgendwas aufsetze.
Oder irgendwie was mal... mal upgradee und mal wieder ordentlich mache.
Nehm ich mir jedes Mal vor.
Max, jetzt lässt es nicht wieder 1-2 Jahre rumgammeln, bis das alles hinten dran ist mit den Updates.
Und dann BÄM.
Doch.
Wie machst du das? An jedem Strip ein ESP32?
Nicht an jedem.
Ich glaube, dass der im Flur sogar noch ein ESP2866 ist.
Ein D1 Mini.
Ich mein, für LEDs reicht's ja.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, dass man das updaten kann.
So ein Ding ist das.
Aber ansonsten ist es bei mir in der Regel ein ESP32.
Ich bin damit aber nicht so ganz glücklich.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile schon recht coole...
So RGB-LED-Controller.
Die dann auch einen passenden Spannungswandler und sowas dran haben.
Dass man beispielsweise auch...
Ähm...
12-Volt-LED-Strips anschließen kann.
Was echte Vorteile hat, wenn's ein bisschen länger wird.
Da muss ja mit dem ESP32...
Da muss ja mit dem ESP32 gehörig aufpassen.
Du hast schon... Was hast du geprickt?
Eine NW-LED-Installation.
Was sind gute Thermostate?
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich hab.
Moment.
Jetzt ist die Frage.
Meinst du Thermostate in Form von...
So Dingern, die bei dir an der Heizung was verstellen können?
Oder meinst du Thermostate...
So Dinger, die an der Wand hängen?
Die dir die Temperatur anzeigen?
Oder meinst du mit Thermostate...
So Dinger, die an der Wand hängen, die Temperatur anzeigen?
Und wo man auch einstellen kann was dran?
Was ist das?
Eigentlich sind Thermostate eigentlich nur die Dinger an der Heizung.
Das andere sind, ja...
Smarte...
Smarthome-Geräte mit nem Display und paar Knöppen.
An der Heizung, ja.
Also da kann ich...
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich habe.
Ich habe jetzt schon seit ein paar Jahren...
Tatsächlich die Fritz...
Die Fritz-Thermostate.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir die jetzt nochmal neu kaufen würde.
So sehen aber meine nicht aus.
So sehen meine nicht aus.
Meine sehen auch anders aus.
Noch...
Ich habe andere Knöpfe.
Ich habe wahrscheinlich das Modell davor.
Das Ding ist halt, die sind relativ teuer.
Ich hatte die damals gekauft.
Das habe ich glaube ich über Geizhals gefunden.
Ja, das sind die, die ich habe.
Genau.
Das ist quasi das Vorgängermodell.
Du hattest 300?
Gab es das auch noch?
Ne, die habe ich schon...
Ich glaube ich habe die 301.
Die sehen genau aus, wie das was ich habe.
Und die habe ich mal in einem größeren Pack gekauft.
Also sprich, entweder war es ein 5er-Pack oder es waren zwei 3er-Packs und ich habe noch irgendwo eins liegen.
Also aktuell habe ich die dran.
Hier oben bei mir im Arbeitszimmer.
Drüben im Wohnzimmer.
Im Flur.
Ist das schon?
Ne, ich habe mehr verbaut.
Unten im Wohnzimmer hatte ich mal eins.
Das habe ich weggemacht.
Denke ich jetzt an irgendwelche ganz obvious Dinger nicht.
Ne, ich glaube das war es.
Ich glaube das war es.
Das sind aber auch die wichtigsten, wo ich will, dass automatisch per Smart Home geregelt werden kann.
Ich hatte auch mal billige mit Zigbee.
Die fand ich ganz grausam.
Die hatten richtig funktioniert.
Die hatten einen super lauten Motor und hatten Probleme.
Das war ganz eklig.
Also seitdem ich diese Fritz-Thermostate habe, bin ich eigentlich echt happy damit.
Ja, es wäre schöner, wenn sich die Dinger über Zigbee oder...
Oder...
Oder meinetwegen auch Wifi steuern lassen würden.
Anstatt zu über DECT.
DECT ist halt so ein...
Wofür braucht man DECT?
Eigentlich nur für so oldschool schnurlose Telefone.
Die Acara-Dinger, die kenne ich.
Das waren, glaube ich, die gleichen, die ich früher auch mal hatte.
Noch unter anderem Namen, die die dann nur unter Acara verkauft haben.
Und die waren nix.
Falls, falls das immer noch so der Fall ist.
Max, du bist doch auch so ein alter Abnehmhase.
Hatte jetzt vor kurzem meine Bruststraffung nach dem Abnehmen.
Wann ist es bei dir soweit?
Du chibadest doch, oder?
Oder hattest du wirklich eine Bruststraffung?
Wie viel hast du abgenommen?
Erzähl mal.
Dann erzähl ich dir, wie es bei mir aussieht.
Ja, ich bin nicht DECT.
Glücklicherweise nicht.
18...
Alter!
Von 150 auf 70.
Okay, es ist der Twitch-Chat.
Wir wissen nicht, aber Michael5Spilian ist immerhin ein VIP-User.
Ich glaub dir das jetzt einfach mal.
Aber das ist super krass.
Ne, ne, passt schon.
Das ist ja super, das ist ja mega krass.
80 Kilo von 150 auf 70.
Also Chat, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal von aus, das stimmt.
Dazu kann man echt nur sagen...
Ich benutze dieses E-Mode nicht, ich finde das nicht.
Ich hatte mal so ein Klatsch-E-Mode.
Oh, hier.
Easy Clap, kann man dazu echt nur sagen.
So, aber ich hab dir versprochen, ich erzähl dir, wie es bei mir aussieht.
Also, bei mir ist das nicht so schlimm, weil ich habe nur, nur von 108,5 abgenommen auf 82.
Also ich hab im Endeffekt dann, was ist denn das, 26 Kilo?
Ne, doch, 26.
Also ich hab nur 26 Kilo abgenommen.
Und das auch über...
Zwei, drei Jahre, ja.
Und dadurch, dass es bei mir nie so krass war, bei welcher Größe...
Ich bin 1,74 und wiege 82 Kilo.
Wir können mal BMI rechnen.
Lass mal kurz BMI rechnen.
BMI rechne.
Adipositas-Gesellschaft.de
Ganz schön adipös das Ganze hier.
Das war mal...
Zu Zeiten, als ich mit dem Dr. Kaboom ab und zu noch...
Zum...
Zum, äh, chines All-You-Can-Eat-Essen gegangen bin.
Da hatten wir so als Insider-Wort Adipös.
Wir haben zu allem gesagt, das ist aber ganz schön adipös.
Fragt uns, fragt bitte nicht, wie wir aus so bescheuerten Ideen gekommen sind.
Also, das ist die Adipositas-Gesellschaft.
Okay.
Größe 1,74, Gewicht 280 Kilo.
Bäm!
Guck mal, ich bin immer noch zu dick.
Immer noch.
Und das, obwohl ich schon so viel abgenommen habe.
Okay, lasst uns mal hier bei...
Bei der Techniker-Krankenkasse, die sind da bestimmt netter drauf.
Da bin ich bestimmt nicht zu dick.
Also, ich bin 40.
Bin 1,74.
Und ich wiege...
82 Kilo.
Pippo-Fat-Time.
Sie wiegen etwas zu viel.
Okay, immerhin. Immerhin etwas zu viel.
Dein Bart wiegt 2 Kilo.
Oh, ich hab aktuell so gut wie gar keinen.
Bart.
Ja, natürlich gibt es sehr viele Faktoren.
Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn du sehr muskulös bist und ein krasser Pumper bist und sowas.
Aber zumindest ein Anhaltspunkt ist der BMI nicht verkehrt.
Max, musst du jetzt auch mehr bei deiner privaten Krankenkasse bezahlen?
Ähm, oh, das ist natürlich ein großes...
Da sag ich gleich was zu.
Da sag ich, da sag ich gleich was zu.
Wenn nicht, erinnere mich dran.
Ähm, so, also.
Wie viel...
Also, ich hab ein bisschen Übergewicht.
Wie viel müsste ich denn wiegen, dass ich normal bin?
Unter 25.
75!
Und...
Alter, ich müsste nur 7 Kilo abnehmen.
7 Kilo ist ganz schön viel, Leute.
Aber du rennst ja auch fleißig und lässt dich von Autos umfahren.
Die letzten paar Wochen hab ich dank Erkältung und, äh, ja...
...sonstigen Sachen gar nicht so viel gemacht.
Bin gestern mal wieder richtig schnell geflitzt.
Und da hat meine Garmin-Uhr gleich gesagt, oh, der ist ja doch schneller, als ich gedacht hab.
Ich renn ja nie, nie immer so ein Kilometer...
Also, ich renn ja nie einen Kilometer auf Zeit.
Ich bin...
Ich hab gestern, gestern hab ich meine normale, meine normale Joggingrunde gemacht.
Und hab mir gedacht, Max, du hast jetzt eine Weile nicht wirklich viel gemacht.
Guck doch mal, ob noch alles klappt.
Und da hab ich einfach gesagt, renn mal einen Kilometer mit, äh, 440er-Pace.
Hab ich gemacht.
War anstrengend.
Aber ich konnte danach die 4 Kilometer noch weiter rennen, für den Rest der Runde.
Also, ich war nicht komplett im Arsch.
Und da hat die Garmin-Uhr gesagt, Max, das war dein schnellster Kilometer jemals.
Ich renn ja nie gezielt auf eine Kilometerzeit.
Ich könnte einen Kilometer noch schneller rennen.
Aber ich war beruhigt, 440 für einen Kilometer, ohne danach umzukippen.
Heißt im Endeffekt, ich schaff wahrscheinlich die 5 Kilometer auch immer...
Wahrscheinlich auch...
Immer noch in bisschen über 25 Minuten.
Also, wenn ich...
Wenn's um Leben und Tod geht, vielleicht auch über... unter 25 Minuten.
Das war ja mein Peak.
Mein Peak war ganz knapp unter 25 Minuten 5 Kilometer.
So.
Da bin ich jetzt aber ein bisschen... bin ich jetzt aber ein bisschen weg schon wieder von.
Aber ich hab jetzt ja wieder angefangen und...
Du schaffst 5 Kilometer... ich schaff sogar 14 Kilometer.
Das längste, was ich bisher gerannt bin, war 14,5 Kilometer.
Allerdings nicht mit 5 Minuten.
Pro Kilometer-Pace.
Sondern mit...
So 6...
6,15, 6,20 so rum.
Ja, also 75 Kilo müsste ich wiegen, dass ich nicht zu fett bin.
Das ist natürlich...
Nicht ohne.
Wann der Halbmarathon?
Das war geplant.
Halbmarathon war geplant.
Im Sommer.
Aber irgendwie war's dann anstrengend auf der Arbeit und alles mögliche.
So, dann hab ich nicht mehr so viel gemacht.
War im Sommer geplant.
Hab ich nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Werde ich wahrscheinlich jetzt im Herbst machen.
Ich renn von Hanau nach Seligenstadt und zurück.
Das sind so...
21,5 Kilometer.
Am Main.
Mein Radweg lang.
Das ist ungefähr ein Halbmarathon.
Also ich bin relativ zuversichtlich, dass ich's packe.
Weil wie gesagt, 14,5 Kilometer konnte ich rennen, ohne dass ich danach umgekippt bin.
Das ist dann halt nochmal 6 Kilometer, 6,7 Kilometer weiter.
Das ist halt ein Drittel nochmal mehr.
Das ist echt ordentlich.
Aber ich muss das langsam machen.
Also ich darf da nicht anfangen mit...
Max, renn das mit...
Renn das unter 6 Minuten pro Kilometer im Durchschnitt oder sowas.
Auch wenn das laut meiner Uhr...
Ja, also meine Uhr sagt ja irgendwie, ich kann das mit 5,30 oder sowas rennen.
Aber das ist schwa...
Danach bin ich dead ge...
Also nee.
Was?
Gibt es Medikamente, die den Puls für circa 1 erhöhen beim Trainieren?
Also wenn du nur einen Puls von 100 hast beim Trainieren,
dann gibt es zwei Varianten.
Entweder...
Also es gibt drei Varianten.
Aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Entweder du trainierst nicht hart genug.
Zweitens, du nimmst irgendwelche Medikamente,
was Blutdruck und so Herzfrequenz und sowas senkt,
dass es einfach nicht mehr geht.
Oder du hast irgendeine Krankheit.
Weil 100er Puls unter Belastung
ist viel zu niedrig.
Die meisten Leute haben einen Ruhepuls,
zwischen...
Also zwischen...
Sagen wir mal bis...
Bis 90 ist okay.
Viele Leute mit einem hohen Ruhepuls haben 90.
Ich habe einen Ruhepuls von...
Von irgendwie mittlerweile 58 oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber so irgendwas...
Tour de France Profis haben teilweise...
Also ich kann mich daran erinnern,
es gab mal ein Interview, Jan Ullrich
hatte glaube ich einen Ruhepuls von 38.
Zu seiner...
Zu seiner Zeit, wo er die Tour de France gewonnen hat.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
dass die aktuellen Profis
wahrscheinlich auch so einen krassen Ruhepuls haben.
35 oder sowas.
Ja.
Aber wenn du nicht über 100 kommst,
ist...
Verdächtig.
Die haben damals nicht alle was reingehauen.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
Radsport ist der einzige Sport,
den ich immer so semiaktiv verfolge.
Und...
Mich juckt es mittlerweile nicht.
Ich...
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass die aktuell sich immer noch was reinhauen.
Aktuell wird natürlich immer erzählt im Radsport,
ja, Nutrition und...
Und neue Trainingsmethoden und neues Material und so.
Also man muss...
Man muss sich das mal vorstellen, ja.
Nur so kleines...
Kleines Sidetracking,
bevor wir jetzt zu der anderen Geschichte kommen.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es hier oben, ja.
Nur...
Nur so kleine...
Für Leute, die sich damit nicht beschäftigen.
So, eines der wichtigsten Zahlen...
Beim Fahrradfahren ist Watt pro Kilogramm.
Körpergewicht.
So.
Und...
Es gibt so ein paar Vergleichszahlen...
Zwischen...
Also an bekannten Anstiegen,
beispielsweise in der Tour de France oder anderen Rennen,
gibt es so ein paar Vergleichswerte...
Zwischen den Profis von damals,
also zu dieser Zeit, wo Jan Ullrich aktiv war,
Lance Armstrong und sowas.
Da gibt es ein paar...
Gibt es ein paar Wattwerte und Watt pro Kilogramm,
und Watt pro Kilogramm Werte für bestimmte Anstiege.
Da weiß man so ungefähr, was die...
Was die gefahren sind, ja.
So über den Daumen gepeilt.
Daku, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und es war jetzt lange Zeit so,
dass die Leute, die danach kamen,
also die Radprofi-Generation, die danach kamen,
die waren not even close.
Bei den Werten und den Geschwindigkeiten.
Also man muss sich mal überlegen.
Ähm...
So 1997, 1998,
rum war das glaube ich in dem Dreh,
wo Jan Ullrich die Tour de France gewonnen hat.
Die Profis haben quasi jetzt 25 Jahre gebraucht,
bis sie an die Werte von damals
Jan Ullrich und Lance Armstrong und so rangekommen sind.
Also da könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wie krass voll die damals gewesen sind mit Zeug.
So, aber mittlerweile ist es so,
also auch die Tour de France Gewinner zwischendurch,
Christopher Froome und wenn es da nicht alle gab,
die an alle not even close Werte,
an den Anstiegen wie damals Lance Armstrong und Jan Ullrich.
Und die anderen zur damaligen Zeit.
Not even close.
Ja, das war eine ganze Ecke unten drunter.
Und damals, da konnte man halt sagen,
okay, man sieht halt richtig krass den Unterschied zwischen
super krass trainiert plus gedoped
und super krass trainiert und nicht so krass gedoped.
Weil die sind halt auf Weltspitze gefahren,
aber not even close.
Also man muss sich mal angucken an den bekannten,
an den bekannten Anstiegen der Tour de France,
halten die Top 20,
sind alles Fahrer aus dieser Zeit von Jan Ullrich und sowas.
Bis heute, bis heute, bis heute.
Aktuell wird das ein bisschen aufgeweicht.
Aktuell wird es ein bisschen aufgeweicht.
So, und deswegen haben, finde ich auch zu Recht,
viele Leute, die Radsport verfolgen,
so aktuell ein bisschen ihre Bedenken,
weil die Profis heute,
die sind so gut,
dass sie quasi schneller sind
als komplett gedopte Lance Armstrongs.
Also der Tour de France-Gewinner und Giro-Gewinner dieses Jahr,
der ist Anstiege schneller gefahren
als zu der krassen Doping-Hochzeit.
Natürlich sagt man heutzutage,
okay, es hat sich ja auch sehr viel geändert,
die Leute wissen besser, wie man trainiert,
das Material ist besser, die Ernährung ist besser,
das mag alles stimmen.
Ob das wirklich diesen krassen Unterschied von legit,
legit fahren und Werte erreichen,
wie einer, der voll gedopt ist,
ich kann verstehen, dass man da skeptisch ist.
Aber mich interessiert es mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Also Jan Ullrich ist immer noch mein Held,
so aus der damaligen Zeit
und wird es wahrscheinlich auch bleiben.
Und ich gucke Radsport immer noch gerne.
Und mir ist egal, ob die sich irgendwas reinhauen oder nicht.
Aber es ist richtig krass, also,
man muss sich das nur mal,
ich versuche euch das mal so ungefähr zu erklären.
Also,
dass man sich mal vorstellen kann,
mal zwei Beispiele,
dass man sich das vorstellen kann,
wie krass manche Profisportler sind.
Ich habe mir das früher,
ich habe mir das früher selbst nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich meine, jedem ist klar,
jedem ist klar,
dass
Weltklasse-Profis schon etwas besser sind,
wie so der normale Durchschnittssportler, okay?
Egal in welchem Bereich.
Es gab eine Umfrage,
es gab letztens eine Umfrage, Moment.
Umfrage,
England Olympiateilnahme.
Ja.
Einer aktuellen Umfrage zufolge
trauen sich 27% der Britinnen und Briten zu,
sich für die nächsten Olympischen Sommerspiele zu qualifizieren,
wenn sie heute mit dem Training loslegen.
Okay, also,
die haben sich halt noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Die denken halt, ja,
die Profis sind schon gut,
okay, Breakdance war ja auch wirklich grausam, ja.
Die denken sich halt, die sind gut,
aber wenn ich jetzt anfange zu trainieren, dann klappt das schon.
Leute, mal so zwei, mal zwei Sachen zum Vergleich.
Nur mal, nur mal so, nur mal so.
Der Marathon-Weltrekord,
also bissl über 40 Kilometer,
der läuft,
haltet euch mal fest,
der läuft den Kilometer,
in 2 Minuten 50.
So.
Das kann man sich jetzt nicht so vorstellen,
als jemand, der selbst noch nicht versucht hat,
ein bisschen, ein bisschen zu rennen,
ein bisschen zu joggen.
Ich kann euch aber mal sagen,
was ich renne.
Ich renne niemals 2 Minuten 50,
auch nicht über 100 Meter.
Ich renne aktuell,
also,
aktueller Peak bei mir
ist ungefähr 5 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich 5 Kilometer lang renne.
Der rennt knapp über 20 Stundenkilometer den ganzen Marathon.
So.
Und jetzt machen wir das mal,
machen wir das mal zum Vergleich.
Machen wir das mal,
ich mache jetzt mal meine Garmin-App auf
und sage euch mal, was meine Garmin-App prediktet,
wie schnell ich einen Marathon laufen würde.
Natürlich Schwachsinn,
meine Knie würden da wahrscheinlich gar nicht mitmachen,
aber, also das längste, was ich bisher gelaufen bin, waren 14,5 Kilometer, ja.
Das ist, das ist,
wenn man mal sehr, sehr großzügig ist,
die Hälfte.
Das stimmt noch nicht mal.
Das ist ein Drittel ungefähr, ja.
Oh man, so, also.
So, also meine Garmin-App sagt,
ich kann den Marathon rennen
mit ungefähr
6,50er Pace.
Das heißt,
also,
das stimmt nicht wirklich,
aber nur mal, dass man es mal vergleicht.
Und ich mache das jetzt auch schon,
ich renne jetzt ja auch schon eine Weile,
wirklich sehr regelmäßig.
Also 6,50er Pace.
Das bedeutet,
der Typ rennt
mehr als doppelt so schnell,
wie ich.
Der rennt fast,
und jetzt mal übertrieben,
der rennt,
also okay, machen wir es mal anders.
Der rennt
doppelt so schnell wie ich,
über 10,
wenn ich 10 Kilometer renne,
rennt der doppelt so schnell 40,
also die Kilometer über 40 Kilometer.
Das ist übertrieben.
Die sind einfach
übertrieben krass,
die Leute.
Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen,
wie krass Profisportler teilweise sind.
Ja und,
um jetzt mal,
um jetzt hier nochmal auf Jan-Ulrich
und Tour de France und so zurückzukommen.
Worauf es da ankommt,
ist,
also eines der,
eines der großen Leistungsmetriken
im Radsport ist Watt pro Kilogramm Körpergewicht.
So.
Ich sage euch jetzt mal meine
Watt pro Kilogramm Körpergewicht,
ja.
Und dann,
und dann,
weil die von,
oder ich frage,
ich frage euch einfach mal.
Also,
wenn ich 2,8 Watt pro Kilogramm fahre,
dann ist das für mich schon sehr anstrengend.
Und ich kann das auch nicht langen.
Ich kann das vielleicht,
vielleicht 20 Minuten,
nein nicht 20 Watt pro Kilogramm,
2,8,
2,8 Watt pro Kilogramm.
Ich kann das,
ich kann das vielleicht eine Viertelstunde.
Ich kann das vielleicht eine Viertelstunde.
Ja,
das sind ein bisschen über 200 Watt.
Das sind dann irgendwie,
was weiß ich,
200,
230 Watt oder sowas.
Das kann ich,
das kann ich nicht lange.
Das kann ich nicht lange.
Also alles über 170 tut mir weh in den Beinen.
Alles über 170 Watt,
wenn ich es über längere Zeit drehen muss.
170 Watt geht,
170 pack ich.
Da lachen sich die Leute kaputt.
Leute,
die regelmäßig Fahrrad fahren,
die fangen nicht unter 200 Watt an.
Leute,
die regelmäßig Fahrrad fahren,
die fangen nicht unter 200 Watt an.
Aber jetzt,
jetzt überlegt mal.
Also ich packe 2,8,
2,8 Watt pro Kilogramm Körpergewicht.
Und jetzt schätzt doch einfach mal,
Was hat denn so der Tour de France Gewinner gefahren,
an manchen Anstiegen über 40 Minuten?
bei der Tour de France?
Nur mal so im Vergleich,
so 0815 K-Knoop wie ich versus pro,
nur mal so im Vergleich,
0815K-Knub wie ich
versus
Pro. 7 Watt pro Kilo,
ja, das kommt ziemlich gut hin.
7 Watt pro Kilo kommt gut hin, so 6,8
oder irgendwie 6,9 oder irgendwie sowas
in dem Dreh, ja. 7 Watt pro Kilo.
Und um das mal in
reinen Wattzahlen zu sagen,
also ich hab Probleme,
mehr als 170 Watt
konstant zu treten.
Und für den ist
340 Watt aufwärmen.
300, das ist
ein halber Toaster. Mit 700 Watt
kannst du ein Toastbrot toasten.
Für den ist ein halber Toaster
aufwärmen. 340 Watt
oder Watt? Ne, ne, 340 Watt.
Der wiegt, der wiegt
auch nur, glaub,
63 Kilo und ein bisschen kleiner
als ich. Ah, das ist übertrieben
krass. Ja, der
wiegt ja auch weniger als ich, das stimmt.
Deswegen geht man da oftmals ja nach
Watt pro Kilogramm. Körpergewicht.
Watt pro
Kilogramm Körpergewicht ist eine ziemlich gute
Leistungsmittrige im Radsport.
Ja.
Und das ist übertrieben. Das ist so
krass. Das kann man sich
als normal Sterblicher gar nicht vorstellen,
wie krass das ist. 340 Watt
einfach so beim Aufwärmen.
Ich bin ein bisschen, der hat einen Puls von
140, hat er in einem Interview gesagt.
Ein Puls von 140, da tritt
da 340 Watt. Wenn ich 340
Watt trete, das kann ich mal für ein paar Sekunden,
ja, dann bin ich dead
danach, wenn ich das länger als
30 Sekunden gemacht hab.
Also ich kann, ich kann
30 Sekunden
das, was der über
40 Minuten den Berg hochfährt, man.
Ja,
und ich bin mittlerweile
auch
halbwegs brauchbar trainiert. Ist nicht so,
dass ich super krass bin oder so, aber ganz okay.
Ganz okay. Aber das ist einfach
Welten. Das sind wirklich, das sind andere
Universen, wo die Typen unterwegs sind.
Ich hab jetzt einfach mal
gesagt, 30 Sekunden. Wahrscheinlich ist es
recht, vielleicht ist es noch viel kürzer.
Ja doch, 30 Sekunden, 340 Watt krieg ich
vielleicht hin.
Hab ich heute ausprobiert. Aber
das war's. Danach kannst du
mein Oberschenkel, kannst du ab
ähm, kannst du
abpellen mein Oberschenkel danach.
So, aber ich wollte noch irgendwas anderes
erzählen hier. Wolltest du
Krankenversicherung? Okay, gute Frage. Max,
musst du jetzt auch mehr bei deiner privaten
Krankenkasse zahlen? Also, das
ist ein großes Thema. Interessiert's
euch, dann kann ich euch ausführlich was zu erzählen.
Was ist dein
FDP?
Äh, 170. Oder
175 oder sowas.
Deswegen sag ich ja, mir tut alles weh, wenn ich, wenn ich
längere Zeit mehr als 170 fahren muss.
100, 175 oder irgendwie
sowas. Über zwei, aber ich hab bisher
nie den Stundentest gemacht, nur den 20-Minuten-Test.
Ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass der, wenn ich wirklich alles
gebe, bis mir der Oberschenkel abfällt,
der vielleicht ein bisschen höher ist.
Aber nicht viel.
Ich weiß, es lachen sich die ganzen,
selbst die Einsteiger-Leute lachen
sich ja kaputt bei einem FDP unter 200.
Aber so ist das halt. Ich bin
halt kein krasser Fahrrad-Pro.
Was heißt Pro? Für Pro
ist das eh absolut lächerlich.
Die treten 200 morgens
auf der Rolle, bevor sie aufs Klo gehen, so.
Okay, also, dann erzähl ich euch
gleich mal was zur Krankenkasse
beziehungsweise Krankenversicherung.
Geht's hier nochmal kurz durch.
Ja, das hab ich mir auch schon gedacht.
Warum lassen die sich nicht einfach alle legal
dopen und schreiben bei sich drauf, was sie
genommen haben? Da weiß man wenigstens, was funktioniert.
Daku, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, Pogacar,
der Typ ist so übertrieben krass.
Der ist ja so heftig, dass sogar seine
Mitprofis sagen, das ist nicht von
dieser Welt, was der tritt. Und ich kann's
verstehen, dass man da echt
skeptisch ist. Okay.
Also, dann erzähl ich euch mal was
zum Thema...
Also.
Die Frage war, Max, musst du jetzt
auch mehr bei deiner privaten
Krankenkasse beziehungsweise Krankenversicherung?
Also, das ist ein sehr komplexes
Thema. Ich versuch da mal ein bisschen was
zu erzählen. Also, ich kann dir jetzt
erstmal easy für
mich beantworten.
Musst du jetzt mehr bei deiner
privaten Krankenkasse zahlen? Da ist die Antwort,
nein, muss ich nicht.
Ich bezahle weniger.
Das heißt aber nicht,
und man sollte sich da auch nicht blenden
lassen, das heißt aber nicht,
dass man langfristig nicht insgesamt
mehr bezahlt, wenn man
privat krankenversichert ist.
Und das liegt an mehreren Punkten,
warum das so ist. Erstens,
die private Krankenversicherung
richtet sich null nach eurem
Einkommen. Die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung schon. Ihr bezahlt
einen festen Satz, ich glaub 14,8% oder
irgendwie sowas,
plus noch einen kleinen Satz jeweils, was
variabel ist zwischen den Krankenversicherungen,
irgendwie so 15% oder sowas,
bezahlt ihr von quasi
von dem, was ihr verdient.
Das heißt, verdient ihr wenig,
bezahlt ihr auch wenig Krankenversicherung,
bezahlt ihr viel,
ähm, ähm, verdient ihr viel,
bezahlt ihr viel Krankenversicherung bis zu einer
gewissen Grenze. Und bis zu dieser
Grenze, wo man bezahlt, wenn man diese Grenze
überschreitet, dann darf man sich auch privat
versichern. Das nennt sich
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze, glaube ich.
So.
Und
das Ding ist halt,
das ist das hier,
ah ja, ah geil,
da freu ich mich ja schon richtig drauf.
18%!
Da fuck!
Aber nächstes Jahr steigt auch die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze.
Na gut, das stimmt aber auch nicht
so ganz, ja.
Weil, bei privaten Krankenversicherungen
ist es so, dass immer eine gewisse
Gruppe von Leuten versichert
ist. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass da
manche Sachen steigen, manche nicht.
Also das ist immer, das ist immer schwer
zu sagen. Also, wo bin ich gerade
stehen geblieben? Also
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung hat natürlich den riesen Vorteil,
das passt sich eurem Gehalt an.
Ja, und wenn ihr viel
verdient, bezahlt ihr viel, wenn ihr wenig
verdient, bezahlt ihr wenig. Ihr bezahlt allerdings
nur bis zu einer gewissen Grenze.
So. Bei der privaten
Krankenversicherung ist es so, es ist scheißegal, wie viel
ihr verdient. Das orientiert sich
null daran. Das orientiert
sich daran, was ihr für einen Tarif abgeschlossen habt
und was ihr da mit dem
Versicherer ausgemacht habt.
So. Jetzt kommt der
Punkt. Wenn ihr
recht viel verdient
und überhalb
dieser Grenze seid, wo ihr euch
privat versichern könnt, bedeutet das,
ihr bezahlt jetzt schon das Maximum
an die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung. Ihr bezahlt
ziemlich viel. Ihr seid natürlich dort auch gerne,
sagen wir mal, gerne gesehen, weil gerade, wenn man
jung ist oder jünger und viel verdient,
dann kostet man nicht viel
und bringt viel Geld ein. Das ist natürlich
super für die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung,
weil irgendwo muss das Geld ja herkommen.
Rentner sind überdurchschnittlich mehr krank, haben mehr
Probleme, also irgendwo muss das Geld ja herkommen.
So. Und jetzt ist
das Ding, jetzt kann man sagen,
ich hab da keinen Bock mehr drauf,
weil man über der Beitragsbemessungsgrenze ist,
ich hab da keinen Bock
mehr drauf, ich such mir eine
private Krankenversicherung.
Und da ist man frei in dem,
was man auswählt.
Man kann sich so einen Billigheimertarif
aussuchen, man kann sich auch
einen super teuren Tarif aussuchen.
Dann muss man natürlich
erstmal Fragen beantworten, wie gesund
man ist. Also wenn man, also wenn ihr
irgendwelche krassen Vorerkrankungen habt,
wie sagen wir mal jetzt irgendwie,
ähm,
ich, äh,
Neurodermitis,
oder, äh,
Asthma,
oder,
keine Ahnung, HIV,
oder irgendwie sowas, dann hat man da
eh keine Chance, dann nehmen die einen
nicht. Aber ihr könnt euch prinzipiell
freien Tarif aussuchen, was ihr haben wollt, von
billig bis teuer.
Und dann ist das meistens erstmal
günstiger, als
in der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung,
weil,
den Teil, den euer Arbeitgeber bezahlt,
ähm, ich rede hier übrigens nur von Angestellten,
wenn ihr selbstständig seid, sieht das wieder ganz äh,
äh, wenn ihr freiberuflich tätig seid, oder selbstständig seid,
sieht das wieder ganz anders aus.
Bei der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
bezahlt ja auch ihr nen Teil und euer
Arbeitgeber nen Teil, so.
Und dieser Teil, den der Arbeitgeber bezahlt,
den bezahlt er auch weiter, wenn ihr
privatversichert seid.
So, und das alles zusammen
sorgt erstmal dafür, dass
viele Tarife, auch die besseren Tarife,
erstmal etwas günstiger
sind, solange man noch arbeiten
geht, dass die noch etwas günstiger sind, als, äh, so.
Als die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung.
Erstmal,
also bei mir ist es ungefähr,
so ungefähr 250, 300
Euro billiger. Also ich bezahle
irgendwie, äh,
ich glaube 400, 400
paar Gequetschte oder so,
im Monat, aktuell.
Mein Anteil, der Arbeitgeber, kommt ja auch
noch dabei. Das ist günstiger.
Also da kann man sagen, aktuell spare ich
Geld, dadurch, dass ich privatversichert
bin. Das Problem bei der privaten
Krankenversicherung ist allerdings,
das richtet sich nicht nach eurem
Einkommen.
Und wenn ihr den Job wechselt, oder
arbeitslos werdet, dann bleibt
das gleich.
Ihr habt die Chance, bis
55, wenn ihr beispielsweise
arbeitslos werdet, oder wieder unter diese
Grenze fallt, dann
könnt ihr, wo wir gerade dabei sind, dann könnt
ihr euch wieder
versichern lassen in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung. Da gibt es jetzt verschiedene
Fallstricke und verschiedene Hürden.
Wenn ihr jetzt einfach nur sagt,
das ist übergangsweise und ich möchte aber
in der privaten Krankenversicherung
bleiben, dann könnt ihr so eine
sogenannte, also keine Beratung
hier, das ist alles das, was ich mir hier selbst
angeeignet habe und gelernt
habe die letzte Zeit, als ich mich damit
beschäftigt, ich bin 40, ja,
mich in letzter Zeit damit beschäftigt habe, dann könnt ihr
eine sogenannte Anwartschaft machen
bei eurer privaten Krankenversicherung.
Dann könnt ihr quasi innerhalb von zwei Jahren
glaube ich wieder zurück wechseln
zu gleichen Konditionen
ohne neue Gesundheitsfragen und sowas.
Ihr könnt auch in den Basic-Tarif
eurer Krankenversicherung wechseln, aber
du kannst prinzipiell wieder zurück in
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung, wenn
dein Gehalt unter
die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze oder
wie das heißt fällt. Da kannst du wieder zurück in die gesetzliche
Versicherung. Aber, und jetzt kommt
das große Aber und warum man sich das wirklich
überlegen sollte, ob man
diesen Schritt überhaupt geht.
Es gibt
die Krankenversicherung der Rentner.
Und die
Krankenversicherung der Rentner,
ist nochmal billiger,
wenn ihr dann in Rente geht,
als die normalen Beiträge zur gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung. Ihr landet
in der Krankenversicherung der
Rentner, aber nur dann,
wenn ihr
in der zweiten Hälfte
eures Berufslebens
zu neun Zehnteln
gesetzlich versichert
wart. Also,
sagen wir mal, ihr wart jetzt
drei Jahre
privat versichert, also keine Ahnung, ihr
seid jetzt irgendwie 50 und
seid jetzt schon ein paar Jahre privat versichert
und sagt dann, ey, das ist mir eigentlich nix,
das wird mir dann auch alles viel zu teuer später
und ihr reduziert
auf Teilzeit, euer Gehalt
fällt wieder unter die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze, ihr sagt,
ich will mich wieder gesetzlich versichern lassen,
dann könnt ihr euch freiwillig
gesetzlich, oder wieder gesetzlich
versichern lassen, das geht. Nicht freiwillig,
ihr könnt euch gesetzlich versichern lassen, aber
nachdem ihr schon so alt seid
und es quasi nur noch 17 Jahre dann
zur Rente sind, dann ist wahrscheinlich
es nicht mehr der Fall, dass ihr
die Hälfte, die zweite
Hälfte eures Berufslebens zu neun Zehnteln
in der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung wart.
Das heißt, ihr landet dann am Ende nicht in der
Krankenversicherung der Rentner
und müsst in der Rente
ein bisschen mehr bezahlen für die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung als jemand, der, sagen wir mal,
die letzten 20 Jahre durchgängig
gesetzlich krankenversichert war. Also, das muss man
bedenken, ja.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch
so, dass man
wenn man es richtig macht,
auch die private Krankenversicherung
nicht unbezahlbar ist im Alter.
Man muss sich das halt
im Vorfeld überlegen, ja.
Also erstens muss man sich überlegen, okay,
will ich den Schritt überhaupt machen,
ja, ist mir das alles, ist mir das
wert drum herum, das ist auch relativ stressig alles,
ist mir das wert?
Viele Leute sagen, ja, ist mir
wert, weil, ne, gibt schnellere
Termine, teilweise bessere ärztliche
Versorgung und was noch immer, was
sonst noch, also hat ja auch
unbestreitbar seine Vorteile.
Aber wenn man sagt,
wenn man sagt,
man will das machen,
dann sollte man sich wirklich überlegen, okay,
ich rechne mal durch, wie ist
so die, wie sieht so ungefähr die Beitragsentwicklung
aus
und wie kann ich das,
wie kann ich das denn finanzieren
alles? Also was kann ich denn, was kann ich
denn machen, dass ich das im Alter
bezahlen kann? Das wird nicht einfach
random teurer,
aber es steigt im Durchschnitt,
so um die, glaube ich,
um die 2% pro Jahr, irgendwie sowas
in dem Dreh und das kann man sich ja mal hochrechnen
und
wenn man in Rente geht,
fällt auch der Arbeitgeberanteil
weg, den muss man dann mitbezahlen.
Also aktuell bei mir ist es
so, bei mir, sagen wir mal, bezahlt jetzt
die Hälfte der Arbeitgeber, die andere Hälfte
bezahle ich, aber sobald ich in Rente
gehe, fällt der Arbeitgeberanteil
weg und den muss ich mitbezahlen,
weil mein Tarif, mein Vertrag
mit der privaten Krankenversicherung,
der wird ja nicht
billiger.
Es fallen mit dem Renteneintritt
ein paar andere Sachen weg, du musst keine
Altersrücklagen mehr bezahlen und du kriegst
noch einen Zuschuss von der
Rentenversicherung und sowas. Ein paar
Sachen fallen weg, also es wird mit dem Eintritt
in die Rente, wird der Gesamtbetrag
ein bisschen billiger,
aber für dich wird es teurer,
weil der Arbeitgeberanteil wegfällt,
wenn du privatversichert bist.
Das heißt, du musst dir im Vorfeld überlegen,
okay, was mache ich? Es gibt da verschiedene
Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel bieten viele
Versicherungen an, dass du im Vorfeld
schon Beiträge
also wenn du zu lang
lebst, wird es verdammt teuer.
Manche Versicherungen bieten an,
dass du schon im Vorfeld quasi
Altersrückstellungen bildest, da bezahlst du dann
ein bisschen mehr
und dann
bekommst du Beiträge im Alter
erlassen,
wobei das ein bisschen fraglich ist, da bin ich
mir selbst unschlüssig, ob sich das lohnt oder nicht,
weil
sagen wir mal so,
sagen wir mal, du bezahlst 150 Euro im Monat
und
davon kriegst du übrigens auch vom Arbeitgeber
was dabei und dadurch, dass du
quasi bis zur Rente
150 Euro im Monat extra bezahlst,
wird dein Beitrag
dran um 300 Euro, sagen wir mal, billiger,
wenn du in Rente gehst.
Oder um, was weiß ich, 400 Euro billiger.
Ich habe das nicht genau ausgerechnet.
Das klingt erstmal gut,
gerade weil der Arbeitgeber ein bisschen was
dazu bezahlt, was dir
allerdings nicht so
offensiv erzählen ist,
dass du diese 150 Euro
Beitragsentlastung auch weiter bezahlst,
wenn du in Rente bist.
Also kannst du diese 150 Euro
von der Beitragsentlastung schon mal abziehen,
was dich da eigentlich wirklich entlastet.
Viele denken nämlich, ich bezahle 150 Euro
Beitragsentlastung
und die fällt weg, wenn ich in Rente
gehe und bezahle dann 400 Euro weniger.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich bezahle dann 400 Euro weniger,
aber die 150 Euro bezahlt er trotzdem noch,
was es dann im Endeffekt nur noch
250 Euro
billiger macht.
Also das ist alles nicht so einfach,
da durch zu blicken.
Also ich kann euch nur empfehlen,
sucht euch da einen ordentlichen Berater,
der das mit euch zusammen macht.
Also das Beste aus meiner Sicht,
was man machen kann, ist tatsächlich
sein Geld, was man über hat,
langfristig irgendwo anlegen,
so dass man dann,
wenn man das braucht,
einen ordentlichen, wie nennt man das so,
Entnahmeplan hat.
Mal angenommen, ihr steckt jetzt alles,
das ist jetzt keine Beratung oder sowas,
aber wer weiß, dass das beliebt ist,
mal angenommen, ihr steckt jetzt
übrig gebliebene Kohle in irgendwie
den World ETF,
der hat im Durchschnitt glaube ich
6,7 oder 6,8 Prozent
steigt der pro Jahr,
wobei das natürlich
sehr schwankend ist,
der kann auch mal fallen
oder steigen und was auch immer,
aber im Durchschnitt hat glaube ich
der MSCI World
die letzten Jahre glaube ich 6,8 Prozent
ist der glaube ich im Durchschnitt
gestiegen, die letzten Jahre über.
Und ich weiß, dass das ein relativ
beliebter ETF ist,
also sagen wir mal, ja gut,
weiß nicht, wo man das hin kann,
aber ich glaube 6,8 Prozent,
so und wenn man sich das selber mal nur
von 5 Prozent ausgeht, kann man
das zum Beispiel anlegen,
ich glaube von Finanzfluss gibt es da
einen ganz guten Rechner,
hier Entnahmeplan, kann man da rechnen,
kann man sagen, okay,
wir legen jetzt,
also ihr müsst euch erstmal ausrechnen,
ihr legt jetzt 100.000 Euro an
oder ihr legt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
ihr spart 300.000 Euro
mit einem ETF
und wenn ihr in Rente geht, habt ihr dann
insgesamt 300.000 Euro, wir können auch
einen ETF-Rechner machen,
gibt es bestimmt auch irgendwelche,
keine Ahnung,
guck hier, MSCI World, durchschnittlich
6,3 Prozent, also sagen wir mal,
keine Ahnung, ihr fangt mit 50.000 Euro
an, wobei der Anfang gar nicht
mehr so entscheidend ist, sondern ihr bezahlt
im Monat, legt ihr da jetzt irgendwie 500 Euro an
und das Ganze
über 20 Jahre, dann habt ihr am Ende
schon ganz gut was zusammen, je nachdem,
kann halt schwanken,
dann habt ihr am Ende schon ganz gut was zusammen
und dann sagen wir, okay,
jetzt geht ihr in Rente,
jetzt geht ihr in Rente, natürlich muss man
immer noch gucken, wie das mit Steuern ist und sowas,
wie gesagt, ich bin da kein Experte und kann euch auch nicht beraten,
ich kann es bloß so ungefähr durchrechnen,
weil ich die Sachen für mich auch durchgerechnet habe,
sondern sagen wir jetzt mal, ihr habt jetzt irgendwie
da angelegt und habt 300.000 Euro
am Start, jetzt kannst du sagen, okay,
wie ist das denn, wenn ich jetzt die nächsten
30 Jahre, sagen wir mal, ihr geht mit
67 in Rente und ihr werdet 100,
ihr werdet 97,
wenn ich die nächsten 30 Jahre
entnehme,
natürlich bleibt das Geld weiter angelegt,
ihr entnehmt da aber einfach nur Kohle drauf,
das heißt, ihr könnt
30 Jahre lang quasi
1590 Euro
entnehmen, bis das Geld weg ist,
also ich habe mein Depot bei scalable,
oder mein Zeug bei scalable,
das reicht
quasi auch, um die Krankenversicherung
im Alter zu bezahlen,
zumindest zum größten Teil,
ja, wenn ihr aktuell, sagen wir mal,
aktuell bezahlt ihr 650 Euro für die
Krankenversicherung insgesamt,
wenn man, also
euer Teil plus Arbeitgeberteil,
sagen wir mal, 650 Euro,
da kannst du davon ausgehen, dass das, wenn ihr in Rente
geht, mindestens doppelt so viel ist,
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr.
Das heißt, man muss auf jeden Fall sich sowas
hier mal durchrechnen, okay, wie viel Geld
brauche ich denn auf der hohen Kante,
dass ich das im Alter alles noch gut bezahlen
kann und
nicht meine ganze Rente weg ist.
Ich hoffe, man
hat es jetzt halbwegs verstanden. Also,
ich würde private Krankenversicherung nur
machen, wenn ich mir relativ
sicher bin, dass ich langfristig genug Geld
verdiene und dass ich
auch langfristig genug Geld,
sagen wir mal, Kohle aufbauen kann in
irgendeiner Art und Weise, dass ich es im Alter bezahlen kann.
Übrigens, hier, umso
länger das Ganze geht, umso besser, ja.
Also, umso früher ihr anfangt,
man glaubt das gar nicht, aber
das ist ein Riesenunterschied, fünf Jahre mehr hier
machen enorm aus. Also,
umso früher ihr anfangt, umso besser.
Mal angenommen, ihr seid jetzt 20
und ihr sagt, ey, wisst ihr was, die übrigens
die 50.000 Euro zum Einstieg sind eigentlich
machen das gar nicht so aus. Wichtig ist eigentlich die
Laufzeit, ja. Wenn ihr sagt,
ey, ich lege jetzt jeden Monat 500 Euro an,
weil man das kann,
und ich mache das jetzt für 30 Jahre,
was ja durchaus geht, wenn man 20 ist,
ja, 20 fängt irgendwie an,
oder wenn du 20 bist, machst du es
gar 40 Jahre, das bringt
richtig was. Viele
Leute sind nicht gut da drin, das
menschliche Gehirn ist nicht gut da drin,
solche,
wie nennt man das, solche
Steigungen zu berechnen, die
quasi
Vorgängersteigungen, so
exponentielle Steigungen quasi zu berechnen,
das kann das menschliche Gehirn nicht gut.
Und da machen
es die, also die Laufzeit ist
eigentlich wirklich das Entscheidende.
Wenn man jetzt, wenn man erst mit 50
anfängt, ist es natürlich ein bisschen schwierig,
ja, aber
sag mal, ich bin jetzt, ich kann das jetzt
20, ich kann das jetzt 20 Jahre lang machen,
oder ich kann es, sagen wir mal so, ich kann das,
ich bin jetzt 40, ich kann das, sagen wir mal, 25
Jahre lang machen, ich würde allerdings,
sagen wir mal, irgendwie mit, sagen wir mal, ich fange mit
100.000 Euro an, bezahle da monatlich
500 Euro rein, da kommt auch schon was zusammen,
aber sollte jeder, der sich sowas
plant, mal so ungefähr grob durchrechnen,
ob das in der Zukunft überhaupt hinhaut.
Ja, ja klar,
klar, du kannst das, du kannst das nie,
nie wissen, das ist
ja durchschnittlich, im Prinzip, du hast hier
Wirtschaftskrise, dann geht's runter, dann ist wieder gut,
dann hast du hier Wirtschaftskrise, und das basiert
ja auch nur darauf, dass man
hofft, dass
die gesamte Weltwirtschaft
in Zukunft weiter steigen wird.
Wenn es irgendwie
den Bach runter geht, dann hast du
mit solchen Sachen eh gelitten.
Es hat natürlich ein bisschen
einen gewissen Ausgleich
drinne, so einen World ETF,
weil du sagen kannst, okay, wenn's
bei uns runter geht, geht's halt in Indien und China rauf.
Oder irgendwo, irgendwo wird's schon rauf gehen,
das heißt, es wird sich vielleicht ein bisschen ausgleichen,
aber wenn's natürlich weltweit runter geht, so
wie 2008,
dann, und das halt für immer,
dann hast du halt gelitten.
Also ich kann's jedem nur empfehlen,
zumindest mal so grob
durchzurechnen, viele Leute denken sich ja zum Beispiel
auch, ey,
ich will nur bis 50 arbeiten, wie viel Geld
brauch ich denn, dass ich bis zur Rente überstehe?
Und sowas in der Richtung, erstens kriegt ihr dann weniger Rente,
eh schon, wenn ihr irgendwie da mal 17 Jahre nicht
gearbeitet habt,
und wie viel man braucht, also
es schadet nicht, zumindest so grob
ein bisschen was im Kopf zu haben.
Was ist denn, was
denn für einen in Zukunft so notwendig?
Also das schadet auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das heißt nicht, dass man jetzt, wie nennt sich das,
dass man so super,
wie heißt das, diese Leute, die quasi so komplett
min-maxen alles an Ausgaben
und Lebensstil,
die so quasi komplett,
komplett minimalistisch leben,
so nach dem Motto,
ich bin Millionär mit 30
oder mit 40, weil ich quasi
nie was gemacht hab in meinem Leben und
nur von Wasser und Gutscheinen gelebt hab.
Frugalisten, genau!
Frugalisten, ja, das meine ich.
Ja.
Nein, den Notfalltarif willst du nicht.
Notfalltarif heißt, es werden bloß akute Sachen,
die jetzt unbedingt gemacht werden müssen, bezahlt.
Und der Basistarif kann im Zweifelsfall sogar
teurer sein als die, also
bisschen teurer oder ähnlich teuer,
wie der Maximalbeitrag zur GKV.
Also, so
so easy ist das tatsächlich alles nicht.
Also, man sollte sich wirklich das gut
überlegen und auch, ob man das in Zukunft alles bezahlen kann.
Ja, und was ich euch
auch noch empfehlen kann, ist eine Sache,
überlegt mal, was ihr für einen Job macht,
ob es nicht in jungen Jahren
sinnvoll wäre, beispielsweise eine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung
oder so abzuschließen.
Also, wenn ihr jetzt sowas macht wie ich, ja,
wenn ihr den ganzen Tag quasi
am Rechner arbeitet
und, also da ist es, es ist, in meinem Beruf
ist es relativ schwierig, berufsunfähig zu werden.
Berufsunfähig heißt, ihr könnt
gar nicht mehr arbeiten. Das heißt nicht zwangsläufig,
dass ihr in eurem aktuellen Beruf nicht mehr vollarbeiten
könnt, sondern gar nicht.
Also, das ist,
das ist als
Kellerkind-Informatiker wie ich,
ist das gar nicht so einfach, berufsunfähig
zu werden. Weil selbst, selbst
wenn mir jetzt irgendwie ein paar Finger fehlen oder so,
ich bin nicht berufsunfähig,
in dem Sinne, da würde keiner großartig was bezahlen.
Also, und selbst, und selbst
wenn man sagt,
ähm, man bekommt jetzt irgendwelche
psychischen Schäden oder so,
selbst da wird ja erstmal so viel an Reha
und allem gemacht, bis du wirklich
berufsunfähig bist, ja.
Und selbst da, selbst wenn du einen Schlaganfall
bekommst, da musst du, das muss schon richtig
krasser Schlaganfall sein, so dass
du quasi so Stephen Hawking,
mäßig dann gar nichts mehr machen kannst.
Ja, dann wäre es vielleicht der Fall. Aber sagen wir mal so,
es ist relativ unwahrscheinlich
in meinem Beruf, oder wahrscheinlich
auch in euren Berufen,
wenn ihr viel IT-mäßig, ich meine, es ist relativ
unwahrscheinlich berufsunfähig zu werden. Aber überlegt
euch das trotzdem mal, weil, wenn ihr jung
seid, ist es relativ günstig
und ihr kommt da rein, weil
ihr keine Vorerkrankung habt.
Ja, also wenn ihr, wenn ihr erstmal
sagen wir mal 40, 50 seid
und, äh, was weiß ich,
schon mal irgendwie bei einer
Therapie wart, oder bei,
oder irgendwie Herzprobleme habt,
oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, dann
nehmt euch keine, nehmt euch keine Berufsunfähig...
Nein, ich habe keine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicher...
Ja doch, sagen wir mal so, ich habe, ich habe
eine kleine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung,
die war bei der
betrieblichen Altersvorsorge vom alten Arbeitgeber
dabei, die bezahlt aber nicht so viel, aber ich habe
keine extra abgeschlossen.
Wäre jetzt der passende Zeitpunkt gewesen,
das mit der Krankenversicherung zu
machen, habe ich aber nicht gemacht,
weil ich mir einfach denke, ey, ich will keine
350 Euro oder sowas im Monat oder 400
Euro im Monat bezahlen, dass ich eine ordentliche
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung habe
und die Chancen sind doch relativ gering.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht, ob es da sowas überhaupt
gibt. Ja, wenn du vorher krank
warst, hast du Ehe, hast du Ehe.
Ehe, das kann schon sein, aber du musst, also es ist
wirklich schwierig, berufsunfähig,
komplett berufsunfähig zu werden als Softwareentwickler.
Gar nicht so einfach.
Ja klar, natürlich kannst
du angefahren werden, du kannst einen Schlaganfall kriegen,
gehen tut das immer, aber du
hast auf jeden Fall Berufe mit deutlich mehr Risiko.
Muss man wissen. Letztendlich
ist es so, es ist eine individuelle Sache
und jede Versicherung ist eine Wette
auf die Zukunft. Ja?
Wenn du sowas abschließt, sagst du
halt, okay, ich bezahle jetzt
Geld, weil ich denke,
in Zukunft könnte mir was Schlimmes passieren.
Es ist immer eine Wette auf die Zukunft.
Egal.
Wenn es danach geht, wenn du dich hundertprozentig
gegen alle Eventualitäten
absichern willst, müsstest du
Notfallversicherung machen, extra Pflegeversicherung
eine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung,
eine Krankenversicherung.
Das kannst du, wenn du jung bist, kannst du das machen.
Dann kommst du auch durch die Fragen ohne Probleme
alle durch.
Aber dann machst du noch einen Zusatz,
eine extra private Rente, dass du den ganzen
Kram im Alter auch weiter bezahlen kannst.
Und dann bezahlst du halt
vier Fünftel
von deinem Geld nur für Versicherungen.
Wenn du wirklich ein komplettes
Programm machst, okay, kannst du das machen.
Ist halt die Frage, ob sich das
dann so lohnt. Also mir reicht
das mit privater Krankenversicherung.
Und
ich hab mein ETF, ich hab mein Sparplan,
ich zahl regelmäßig ein.
Für mich sieht es
aktuell so aus, als passt
das alles.
Am Ende muss sich das jeder selbst
überlegen, wie
abgesichert er sein will und wie
risikobereit, nicht
risikobereit, was auch immer.
Deswegen, es schadet auf jeden Fall
nicht, sich ein bisschen Gedanken drüber zu machen
und sich mal
ein bisschen hier sowas durchzurechnen.
Ich weiß, ich hab das selbst nicht gerne gemacht.
Es ist auch ein
Wie soll man sagen?
Ein unliebsames Thema.
Es ist ein unliebsames Thema.
Niemand macht sich gerne Gedanken über seine
eigene Vergänglichkeit.
Niemand macht sich gerne Gedanken drüber,
okay, was ist denn vielleicht mal in 30 Jahren,
wenn ich in Pflegefall bin.
Niemand macht das. Das kann ich euch als eigene Erfahrung sagen.
Ich hab da auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ich bin da keine Ausnahme.
Meine Mutter beispielsweise sagt mir schon seit
Ewigkeiten, Max,
schreib doch mal eine Patientenverfügung.
Mach doch mal ein Testament und sowas.
Es kann dir doch jederzeit, wenn du Pech hast, was passieren.
Dich kann einer umfahren
und seitdem ich den
Fahrradunfall hatte, bei dem mir nichts
passiert ist.
Nichts. Ich hatte Hautabschürfung
ein bisschen. Nichts.
Seitdem ist die da, ist die
quasi liegt die mir da auch permanent
in den Ohren. Mach mal Testament, mach mal
Patienten, mach mal Vollmacht
und so.
Und jetzt die letzten, die letzten
14 Tage, wo ich so krass erkältet war,
wie gesagt, es war schlimmer als Corona.
Ich hab das tatsächlich gemacht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, ey
Max, du siehst mal, auch wenn es nur eine Erkältung
ist,
wie
schnell es gehen kann.
Ja, der Twitch Chat.
Also wisst ihr, was ich
machen würde? Also wenn ich, wenn ich wirklich
mal irgendwie alt bin und abkratze
und ich bis dahin kein Nachwuchs oder
irgendwelche anderen Verwandtschaft, whatever
habe, ja, kann ja durchaus passieren.
So toll wie ich
zwischenmenschlich da Skills
habe, dann
werde ich einfach
Haus und Vermögen
dem Tierheim überschreiben, so.
Oder vererben.
Wenn es bis dahin niemand gibt.
Da können die, können die sich freuen und
alle Katzen der Welt
heile machen, so.
Naja, aber
wie gesagt, ja, Catstream wird schwierig,
wenn ich den Löffel abgegeben habe.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, es macht sich echt keiner,
keiner gerne Gedanken so über die eigenen Sachen.
Ich kann euch aber aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, so
ab 40,
ab 40 fängt man an
sich ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen, ja.
Weil man halt merkt, okay,
es ist nicht mehr alles so wie mit
und du bist auch nicht mehr jünger.
Da fängt man an sich ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen.
Und man hat es beim Krieger gesehen,
das Video wollte ich mir auch noch mit euch angucken, hier.
Ähm, einfach weil es mich echt
geschockt hat ein bisschen.
Dass das ganz schnell gehen kann.
Bin kein Millionär.
Mir geht es nicht schlecht, aber Millionär bin ich nicht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht
wenn man wirklich
alles, inklusive dem, was ich
eher über dem Haus zusammenrechne, vielleicht
ganz, ganz, ganz
knapp, aber wahrscheinlich
auch eher nicht.
Also aktuell bin ich ganz weit davon entfernt.
Das kann ich euch sagen.
Aber ganz weit.
Aber es schadet
auf jeden Fall nicht, sich da echt mal ein bisschen
Gedanken zu machen. Jetzt vielleicht nochmal,
weil wir gerade mal ein bisschen
bei ein bisschen serious,
serious Themen sind. Letzte Woche,
ich habe euch,
ich habe euch das ja schon mal erzählt. Ich glaube, ich habe euch das schon mal
erzählt, weil das auch eine Sache war, die mich
persönlich schon ein bisschen mitgenommen hat.
Ähm, äh, so mit
mein bester Freund, oder so einer meiner
besten zwei Freunde aus der Schulzeit,
ich
verdiene nicht 100k plus im Jahr, weil ich Teilzeit
arbeite. Ähm, so einer meiner
besten Freunde, oder einer meiner besten
zwei Freunde aus der Schulzeit,
der hat sich umgebracht vor
einem Jahr, vor eineinhalb
Jahren, 2023.
Der war ungefähr so halb
wie ich. Und
das, was ich gehört habe,
ist, dass er die
die Trennung von
quasi
Frau und Kind nicht verkraftet hat.
Und das hat mich echt mitgenommen.
Ich weiß
es auch noch nicht so lang. Ich habe es euch, ich habe euch das
glaube ich schon mal erzählt. Das hat mich
echt mitgenommen. Und
nachdem, nachdem es mir die
letzten 14 Tage, nachdem ich so krass erkennbar
war, und ich, äh,
ja, immer ein bisschen an die frische Luft
musste. Ich hatte die letzten 14 Tage
wirklich sehr viel Zeit, mich so über,
gerade, gerade weil ich so krank war, ja, weil
ich so mit dem Bett, dicker Hals und alles,
konnte nicht richtig pennen dadurch,
gelegen habe, habe ich mir viel, viel Gedanken
gemacht über so, so Dinger hier, ja.
Und als
es mir wieder ein bisschen besser ging, bin ich,
bin ich
am Friedhof vorbei.
Ich, ich hatte mit meinem, mit dem Freund damals aus der Schule
die letzten Jahre über kaum was zu tun.
Wir hatten auch, wir haben auch nicht viel gesprochen.
Das letzte, das letzte, was ich mit ihm zu tun hatte, war
damals, als er sein Kind gekriegt hat,
also, als er Vater geworden
ist, muss man besser sagen, habe ich ihm damals
noch geholfen, in einer neuen Wohnung einen Schrank zu sagen.
Zu bauen. Da waren wir irgendwie knapp 20 oder so.
Und seitdem hatte ich mit ihm nichts mehr
zu tun. Und
ich wusste aber, auf welchem Friedhof er ist. Ich bin da,
das ist nicht weit, ist nicht so weit weg von hier.
Ich bin da mal vorbeigelaufen und habe das,
habe das gesucht. Und
da habe ich so gestanden und
da ist es mir echt so,
so gedämmert, wo ich mir gedacht
habe, ey Max,
das kann schnell, kann schnell vorbei sein.
Ja, man guckt sich, guckt euch das Video,
guckt euch das Video vom Krieger an.
Das kann, es kann echt schnell vorbei sein.
Und
man macht sich über so viel Scheiße
Gedanken, Leute. Über so viel,
über so ein Mist.
Man hat, man hat permanent Probleme im Kopf.
So, oh, das könnte scheiße
und manchmal
macht man dann, phantasiert man sich noch Probleme
zusammen, so, ah, das könnte schlecht laufen
und dann könnte das passieren und jenes passieren und hier passieren.
Anstatt
tatsächlich mal
zu versuchen, zumindest ein bisschen positiv
auf das Ganze zu blicken
und zu sagen, ey Leute,
ich bin hier,
mir geht es aktuell gut,
ich habe keine schlimmen
Erkrankungen, ich habe einen super
nice Twitch-Chat, ich
verdiene genug Kohle,
ich habe ein paar Freunde, mit denen man reden kann,
Sport läuft gut.
So nach dem Motto, warum
hat man nur den Hang dazu,
mehr an negative
Sachen zu denken, als an positive Sachen.
Das, das habe ich, das war der,
das war wirklich der Gedanke, den hatte ich,
als ich da am Grabstein
von ihm gestanden habe, habe ich gesagt, warum,
warum denkt man einfach nur immer,
man hat
so den Hang dazu, weil das Negative
überwiegt einfach im Kopf. Negativ ist das,
wo man sich Gedanken drüber macht, ja, weil es halt
was ist, wo das Hirn weiß, oh, Achtung,
da ist was Gefährliches
und oftmals sind ja die Gedanken,
die man hat, die sind so abstrakt auch nur,
wo man sich denkt, oh, ich hab,
ich hab da und davor
Bedenken und dann malt
man sich Horrorszenarien aus, was könnte passieren,
und sonst wie und dann, dann verstärkt sich
das noch.
Man hat einfach den Hang dazu,
an so viel negative Sachen zu denken
immer. Es gibt genauso viel
gutes Zeug.
Das nimmt man aber oftmals so als
gegeben hin, wo man sagt, ey,
ich,
für mich ist klar, dass ich,
äh, mobil bin,
dass ich keine Krankheiten habe, für mich ist
klar, dass ich das und das machen kann, für mich ist klar, hier
Internet, alles, aber vieles
von dem, was man so als
so ganz selbstverständlich
sieht, wo man sich so, wo man, wo man sich gar nicht
anders vorstellen kann, sagt jemand, das war schon immer
so, das kann, wird nie anders sein,
kann ganz schnell vorbei sein.
Und, also was ich auch
gemerkt hab, ist, was wirklich
hilft, und das klingt jetzt super nach,
keine Ahnung, indischem Guru oder
sowas, aber es hilft wirklich,
was hilft, wenn man schlecht drauf ist, oder wenn man,
ja, wenn man an negative Sachen
denkt, ist tatsächlich,
wie soll ich das ausdrücken, so,
nicht nur, nicht nur an die Sachen
denken, die, die, die gut sind, sondern
auch mal, auch mal so ein bisschen
dankbar im Kopf sein, dass man
sagt, okay,
ich kann echt dankbar dafür sein,
dass das
alles so gut geklappt hat immer,
ja, ich weiß genau, es hätte
an vielen Momenten genau anders rumlaufen
können, aber ich hab Glück
gehabt, das lief gut,
dass man auch mal sich der Sache
bewusst wird, und
was eigentlich alles gut ist,
was gut läuft, und was man eigentlich hat,
so, genug ZG-Thema,
aber das, das ist das, das, das ist genau
das, was ich wirklich dort gedacht hab,
als ich bei ihm am Grab gestanden hab,
ich hab übelst geflennt,
ja, obwohl ich
mit dem 20 Jahre nix zu tun hatte, wie gesagt,
als wir um die 20 waren,
das letzte, was ich mich erinnern kann, dass ich mit ihm zusammen
einen Schrank, einen Schrank zusammengebaut habe,
und dann 20 Jahre nix zu tun gehabt,
und dann hast halt gehört,
so, genug
ZG-Thema, aber da hatte
ich die letzten 14 Tage Zeit, mir da Gedanken drum
zu machen, das wundert mich nicht,
dass das das Leben verlängern kann,
das sorgt für bessere Durchblutung,
und gute Durchblutung ist immer nicht verkehrt,
tja,
wir gucken uns jetzt, wir gucken uns auch nicht
das Video vom Krieger an, das ist jetzt auch vielleicht,
nachdem ich schon so viel, so viel
ZG-Zeug erzählt hab, nochmal, nochmal,
das heben wir uns auf,
ja, genau, und ich finde,
das ist was, wo man, wo man wirklich mal
drüber nachdenken kann, es ist
gar nicht alles so scheiße, wie es immer aussieht,
man sieht einfach nur
die Scheiße zuerst,
und macht sich da drüber Gedanken,
aber um die Scheiße
drumherum gibt's auch vieles, was gar nicht so scheiße ist,
guckt euch mal an, so ein Beispiel,
auch wenn das viel, wenn das viel
schlecht, schlecht geredet wird,
so, so nach dem Motto,
es war noch nie so, noch nie so schlecht wie heute,
guckt mal, was das Thema
persönliche Entfaltung angeht,
du konntest dich noch nie so gut,
also, ich rede jetzt hier von Bones in, hier in
Deutschland, ja, dass es da Probleme auf der Welt gibt,
in manchen, äh, Ländern
ist das, äh, ohne Frage, ja,
du kannst dich hier persönlich super
entfalten, guckt mal, es juckt
niemand, keine Sau juckt das,
dass ich mit 40 Jahren
vorm Rechner sitz, in Twitch Emotes
rede und sonst nix mache,
ok, bisschen Sport, ok, ja,
du, du hast kaum noch Belehrungsleute
am Start, früher hätten dir die Leute erzählt,
Max, mach doch sowas nicht, was soll in deiner Zukunft
passieren, du kriegst viereckige Augen,
und sonstige Geschichten, ja, wenn ich
heute mich hier auf Twitch hinstellen würde
und ich sage, Leute, ich bin schwul,
also, es wird keinen jucken, klar, es gibt
immer noch die einen oder anderen Verrückten,
die da was dagegen haben, aber
im Großen und Ganzen kannst du
dich heute persönlich so gut
entfalten, wie noch nie zuvor, und das ist doch eine super
Geschichte, du musst dich heute nicht mal
verstecken, egal was ist, du kannst
eigentlich so gut wie immer machen, was du willst,
solange sich andere Leute zu dir einstellen,
vollkommen, das ist eigentlich eine richtig super Geschichte,
da haben wir es wirklich gut,
und ich denke, das ist auch was, was man
auch mal sehen muss, es wird immer so negativ
geredet, ja, es gibt immer mal Probleme,
dass Leute
das nicht wollen,
ja, was andere machen,
aber im Großen und Ganzen
ist das hier wirklich nicht schlecht,
und da bin ich
echt froh drüber, dass das so ist,
also, es gibt wirklich auch vieles,
was gut läuft und was gut ist, und worüber man sich freuen kann,
man muss ja nicht gleich so sagen, man muss ja nicht
gleich anfangen zu beten und sagen, oh, ich bin so dankbar,
ihr wisst, dass ich von Brage und sonstigen
und sonstigen religiösen Sachen, da habe ich
nicht viel mit am Hut,
aber es macht, es
versetzt einen selbst in etwas,
ja, es lässt einen selber
etwas positiver denken, wenn man
mal versucht, auch so die,
nicht nur die schlechten Sachen zu sehen, ja.
Zum Beispiel freue ich mich, dass
ihr alle am Start seid heute auf Twitch,
obwohl ich jetzt fast einen Monat nicht on war.
Instant 150 Leute
am Start gewesen, richtig pock.
Und ich wollte eigentlich seit 50 Minuten schon
off sein und was futtern.
Würdest du das auch über die Deutsche Bahn sagen?
Du meinst, dass man auch der Deutschen Bahn was Positives abgewinnen kann?
Glaub mir,
sogar an der Deutschen Bahn könnte
man, wenn man sich viel Gedanken macht,
das ein oder andere Positive abgewinnen,
allerdings nicht viel.
Oh, sad girl, ja.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Ich glaube, sogar an der Deutschen Bahn
könnte man, ja, also ich meine,
allein schon, dass es sie gibt,
ist ja was Positives.
Das, was sie leistet, ist natürlich
abgrundtief scheiße, aber
zum Beispiel, dass die Bahn das mittlerweile
selbst gecheckt hat
und doofe Sprüche macht über
Lautsprecher, wenn es wieder nicht läuft.
Du kannst sogar der Bahn das ein oder andere
Positives ab, genau.
Das Personal, das ist auch sowas, was sich
auch der Bahn Positives abgewinnen kann.
Ein Großteil des Bahnpersonals gibt sich
wirklich Mühe. Ja, viele sind auch
Pissed. Gut, die USA ist
auch ein bisschen weitläufig,
könnte man so sagen.
Und bei den Amis fahren die auch alle gerne
so Minitrucks und sowas.
Ja, aktuell, also, wie gesagt,
die letzten 14 Tage war ich super
heftig erkältet.
Ähm, ich bin
am Dienstag war das, ja,
vorgestern bin ich nach Frankfurt gefahren.
Warte mal, heute ist Donnerstag, oder?
Vorgestern bin ich nach Frankfurt
gefahren und da ging das tatsächlich
ganz gut.
Mit der Bahn, ausnahmsweise mal.
Guck dir die, wenn
du in der Schweiz guckst, ist das super mit der Bahn.
Generell, viele, viele, die
aus dem Ausland kommen, wenn die
zum ersten Mal Kontakt mit der Deutschen Bahn haben,
haben die so einen Schock, weil die
denken in ihrem Hinterkopf immer noch,
ja gut, steigst du halt in den Zug und du
fährst da hin und du kommst auch an.
Aber so ist das bei der Bahn ja nicht.
Gerade wenn du beispielsweise an der
Endstation aussteigen willst, kann es
durchaus sein, dass der Zug sagt, ah fuck, wir sind schon so
spät, wir hören einfach zwei, zwei
Haltestellen vor der Endstation auf
und drehen um.
Kann eben bei der Deutschen Bahn passieren.
Ja, da sind viele Leute
geschockt, die das nicht vorher kennen.
Viele denken
auch, ja, wir sind ja im Ausland auch so ein bisschen
bekannt, als dass wir super, super ordentlich
und pünktlich sind und sowas, ja. Man würde,
man würde bei diesem Ruf ja auch erwarten,
dass wenn was in Deutschland gut
funktioniert, dass es dann sowas ist wie die Bahn.
Aber ich glaube, da muss
jeder so seine
eigenen negativen Erfahrungen mitmachen, ja.
Dass das, dass die Bahn halt doch
suckt.
Aber Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur kurz mit euch schwätzen und sagen, dass ich nicht
deadge bin. Es freut mich
sehr, dass so viele da waren.
Obwohl ich jetzt fast einen Monat nicht
on war. Danke für die ganzen
Subs. Guck mal, ob ich hier irgendwas
vergessen habe.
Nee. Richtig nice.
Community Girl, genau.
Jetzt wieder regelmäßig, ja.
Ich hoffe mal schon, ja.
Wir hören uns. Macht's gut.
See you.